[Music]
it is us it is Friday it's the History
Podcast we're here and we have got a
great show
and you've got big ass
big Tails pigtails
came like a disco ball do not mess with
me slay Queen you probably could do some
damage with that thing ah you hit me
with it
oh no
yeah and tell me I've been very bad tell
me I've been very bad boss
very bad oh yeah oh I've been dirty tell
me I'm 30. not in the first minute of
the episode
welcome everybody yes it's April 17th a
beautiful
is it spring today is today the first
day I'm so ready is it that's the 20th
we're very close actually it's kind of
nice out today yeah it's a little bit
warmer but anyway
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey and Native who we love love love
oh yeah whip me Daddy sponsors
foreign
[Applause]
as you guys know this the one thing we
know about the Irish is that they're a
bunch of degenerate alcoholics
apparently because that's all you do not
degenerate I just like to drink I guess
well it's like all of a sudden in
America I don't know anything about
Irish culture except that they drink
that's it it's like nobody cares here
about the Irish like you got people out
here at the end of the year you got
people who probably didn't even know
Ireland was a country and they're
walking around with four leaf clovers
green and getting getting pissed on on
Guinness yeah I guess that's kind of
like the beauty of the year the beauty
of humanity
yeah it's like all the stuff like of all
the holidays that we care about St
Patrick's Day you know and it's so big
here it's huge every frat house every
Young Person's house around the country
is draped in green baby whatever
is he doing a little Jamaican
before these plovers man
of the year I don't even know what
you're saying give me that the four leaf
clovers okay that's the eye look look at
the Irish
yes little I say leper cards and pots of
gold it's being pointed out that neither
of you are wearing green I know
oh wow
that's epic oh you did it in school
if you weren't wearing green you would
get harassed people would pinch you and
harass you it's like why all of a sudden
everybody cares about the Irish also all
of a sudden everybody's okay with
pinching each other it is so painful
it's amazing Nails yeah it's violent
yeah it's a violent holiday so this is
it so when we honor the Irish we we are
committing acts of violence and getting
belligerently drunk I dressed like my
favorite alcohol Rose okay Rose because
we Rose all day okay Queen pop off nice
I'm half Irish by the way
my mom's Irish are you really what yeah
not even wearing green I am not even
wearing it up is your mom like
full-blown Irish uh she has some German
in her as well but predominantly Irish
but you don't even drink so you lose 25
right yeah that's true yeah that doesn't
work out bro
I wonder what do the Irish think of
Lucky Charms they think they're
magically delicious because like if you
that's like kind of
racially insane
why because if you if like imagine in
Ireland they had like the Jews gold oh
I'm the little juice gold
find me Jewish gold
like it's insane it's like I'm a little
leprechaun
find the marshmallows at the end of the
rainbow So Lucky Charms come in Jamaican
again yeah it's a leprechaun and the
Lucky Charms is like an Irish like stair
like Trope I had no idea luck of the
leprechaun I don't even think the Irish
people care about St Patrick's Day to be
honest with you I don't even think it's
a big holiday over there is that right
yeah that's my understanding that's
right that's how I feel learning about
like American Jews like it's very
different from people in Israel like you
guys do Hanukkah so big here and I feel
like Israel people don't care about the
minor holiday it's like yeah okay
whatever that's very nice
you know
that is very interesting so who is say
oh I was going to say you know it it
doesn't surprise me because Irish people
get pissed drunk every night and tap
dance and Riverdance and [__] they don't
do that that's very racist they just
riveted off their way down
respect our Irish fans that's how they
put themselves to bed at night I'm
trying to make a point in that why are
we what's with the Irish phobia
aerophobia um here Emma said literally
no one in the UK cares so so this is a
uniquely American thing it's so awesome
yeah it's pretty much an American
holiday at this point
people are pointing out it's like Cinco
de Mayo for Mexicans uh
no I'm Cinco de Mayo is big in Mexico
but is it though like the way it's big
here
oh well I thought what is Cinco de Mayo
The Day of the Dead that's the day we
have a lot of uh Mexican viewers
no that's the
okay so they say yeah you remember the
anniversary of Mexico oh it's Mexican
Independence
I don't think it even is
well if you're reading something but but
you're right we go [__] we love other
people here in L.A you're right and
Cinco de Mayo we pop off it's tequila
all around I mean it is a cool one I
love all the art that goes with it
Americans only celebrate the fun ones
they don't celebrate Ramadan or anything
they're they're like yeah yeah you guys
don't do Yom Kippur do you
the Jewish American they do I observe
that yeah you do yeah you fast not well
but I observe it
I acknowledge it I acknowledge it hey it
happened I mean no a lot of you do I
mean I know you like no water no
brushing your teeth
fast not that's hardcore that's what it
is yeah I know electricity
no NADA no brushing your teeth hell no
because it's got water in your mouth
yeah oh the a lot of people cheat but
these these people go a day without
drinking water I'm like yeah that's the
hardest part keep that [__] God wants me
hydrated
yeah but who what did Saint Patrick even
do like what's so good dope about St
Patrick he kicked all the snakes out of
Ireland that's pretty dope snakes what's
wrong with snakes I don't know there's
Satan or something I don't know
um I think the big thing to know about
St Patrick's is uh St Patrick's St
Patrick is uh he was not Irish right
he's the Apostle of Ireland he was Roma
Romeo Romano British why does it lie
he was a bishop in Ireland
right the patron saint of Ireland and
other Patron States whatever who cares
about the other ones
um Patrick was never formally canonized
so what the [__] wait what
that's pretty wild he lived before the
first laws of the Catholic church in
these matters he's a poser he's not
canon he he no he he was a saint before
it was cool to be oh he's like a hipster
fan yeah extended Universe Christian so
what did he do what why why do we care
let's see life
let's see he was born at the end of the
Roman rule in Britain his birthplace is
unknown fascinating
um he let's see
he blah blah blah there's a Roman town
known as this name I'm not going to
attempt
okay
so here it is according to the
confessions of Saint Patrick at the age
of 16 he was captured by a group of
Irish Pirates
from his family's Villa they took him to
Ireland where he was enslaved and held
captive for six years Patrick writes in
the confessions
that the time he spent captivity was
crucial to his Spiritual Development he
explains that the Lord had mercy on his
Youth and ignorance and afforded him the
opportunity to be forgiven his sins and
convert to Christianity
while in captivity he worked as a
shepherd and strengthened his
relationship with God by [__] sheep
and I know sorry that wasn't in there uh
through prayer actually through prayer
which led him to convert through
Christianity after six years captivity
he heard a voice
telling him that he would soon go home
and that the ship would be ready fleeing
his Masters he traveled to a port 200
miles away where he found a ship
bro I don't care tell me what he did for
God
he uh after sustained they cut her well
wild wild boar
uh he revealed I saw he says recounts of
vision he had after returning home I saw
a young man as it were from Ireland his
name was Victorious and he carried many
letters
and he gave me one of them I read the I
read the heating the voice of the Irish
as I began the letter I imagined in that
moment that I had heard the voice of
those very people who sat near the woods
of folklit apples that's not your ID
they cried out we appeal to you holy
servant boy come and walk among us
so God
uh said walk among them
whatever the [__] that means
Legend here's his life so much this is
the good stuff here's the Legends Legend
credits Patrick with teaching the Irish
about the doctrine of the Holy Trinity
by showing people the Shamrock
a three-leafed plant he used to teach
them about the Holy Trinity what's up
now dude okay that's fire
the earliest written version of the
story is given by the botanist Caleb
threck held
in 1726 whatever
in the Pagan Ireland three was a
significant number and the Irish had
many triple deities
the fact that may have aided Patrick and
his evangelicalization efforts
he also kicked out all the snakes you
guys are right why do you do that
it was a little bit overboard
let me ask you this is there still
snakes in Ireland now because he could
he's like no the famously no snakes in
Ireland
the British government
in Northern Ireland oh [__] here we
go
here we go wait are you you're serious
Ireland was well known to be a land
without snakes there you go and this was
noted as early as third Century but
later Legend credited Patrick with
banishing all the snakes from the island
this man did it he said no more goddamn
snakes on this goddamn plane
the earlier text mentions an Irish saint
is that is that really saintly to just
Slaughter animals
the earliest right you want to do you
want to do me a favor get rid of all the
mosquitoes that that'll that's
impressive you know that would be a man
to work [__] or a woman yeah
whoever can get that done the earliest
writings about Patrick raiding Ireland
of snakes
over Jacqueline of furnace in the late
20th century says Patrick chased them
into the sea after they attacked him
during his fast
so they attacked him and he said I'm
chasing all these [__] snakes
into the oceans in the entire Island
all attacked him okay so I guess that's
about it though the man just killed a
bunch of snakes that's really all it
takes
okay
doesn't seem like a lot
so
um the one thing that stands out to me
though the most about
the St Patrick's Day in particular
is you have this drink that's very
popular here in America it's called The
Irish car bomb
and much like the
um leprechaun imagery this one is like
just straight up insane thing to call a
drink because they had like a really
bloody Civil War and they're blowing up
cars and killing people and it was like
a horrific time and here we are doing
Irish Car Bomb it's like politically
charged it's insane right I mean the
Irish people must not love that title of
that drink
I had a friend that went to Ireland and
he asked for one at a bar and he got
kicked out of the bar for it
[Music]
cancel that drink so they know about it
or were they just like dude what's wrong
with you they know about it and they're
not fans why so why is it
a drink here it's it's like not just a
drink here it's like a popular drink
it's the drink yeah this is so weird
oh they're trying to Rebrand it as the
Irish Slammer is that right
that cocktail's name refers to a
decade-long period of violence in
Northern Ireland the tensions are deeply
rooted in the history of Ireland and its
colonization by Great Britain I should
call it the juicer
the Irish juicer
so that's kind of crazy to me it's like
calling like making a drink like the the
you know the
the train to Auschwitz or something it's
like what why are we doing that so
actually hey Gabe hold on one sec there
I see you're enjoying uh uh St Patty's
Day as well as we are
um so our segment we planned today we
took that and ran with it we says if
we're going to make offensive drinks
about Ireland that we're going to make
offensive drinks about everybody
and so we've made cocktails with the
most offensive things we could uh think
of and we're going to be slamming them
and getting trashed
on uh political incorrectness
yes yes yes
um can I propose to the Irish people
I don't know if they have one but I
think there should be a cult day
where like can you imagine if everybody
wore
a killed skirt
s are badass bro they're so cool because
I want to wear a kilt right I like that
they figured out like well I want to
have a breezy fun time and clothing so
they figured that out for the guys my uh
my mom's side of the family is Scottish
um which are also very famous for their
Kilts and I went to Scotland and found
like the the family pattern because the
Kilts are actually all the patterns on
them are specific to different Clans so
I found we're McKays so I found the
McKay Clan Kilt but a real like a legit
one yeah thank you it was like over a
thousand dollars over a thousand dollars
and and this was
oh six ish so it's probably no idea it
was like from like authentic uh sheep's
wool from the highlands of Scotland and
everything I'm sure
but like the really legit crazy I
couldn't afford it nope I guess I'm not
doing that I wonder if they sell them
like second hand probably yeah I guess I
it yeah Tartan right that's what it's
called right
so Gabe I see you're celebrating St
Patrick's Day is this a big holiday for
you
oh no I'm [__] up oh you're already
drunk
I had six glasses of beer this morning
holy [__] Bro oh
um okay correction Kyoto Scottish not
our Irish oh [__] exactly it's not a day
yeah I looked it up they do wear it in
Ireland though can I still propose that
day yeah yeah
I'll tell you something though when I
was in college everyone was trying to be
like cool and hip
and like Trailblazers and there was a
guy who I was friends with who started
wearing like a kill yeah like he didn't
wear underwear
so this man was his [__] dick and
balls was constantly on display and that
wasn't cool
that part I didn't like about it
[Music]
Kilts are definitely part of Ireland's
culture many consider that the Irish
first played bagpipes and the Scots
first war kills okay so it's a little
collaboration yeah Gabe
um what does St Patrick's Day mean to
you
it means green and celebration
time to get [__] up
it's [__] up day yes
[__] oh hey Gabe why why do we
celebrate St Patrick's Day do you know
anything about the holiday
oh I guess it's like an excuse to just
drink yeah it's an excuse to drink there
you go
we don't we don't care about the Irish
do we gave
I don't think so we just wanted to know
yeah
and that's it where you guys are out in
public getting trashed I like that
shut up
their backyard wait really that looks
like you have a beautiful bathroom yeah
looks like a beautiful backyard or
something are you guys really in the
backyard it's on the backyard show in
the backyard damn it looks nice back
there huh
yep not very good reception though I'll
tell you yeah
[Laughter]
oh my God I can listen to my balance oh
yeah Gabe you got started early my dude
I love that for you but that's how we
honor the Irish and that's why um
that's why we care about the Irish we
honor that I bet America has a little
bit of Irish in US absolutely but it is
all right look when it gets tiny Amen
brother amen amen
hey I would look at the Irish [__]
listen the Irish [__] ride this rainbow
into my dick [__]
ride the green choke it your ass is
green [__] hey [__] yeah hey guess what
happy Saint Patrick's Day there's green
slime coming out the tip of my dick baby
[Music]
green boogers off my nose and
put it in your mouth
hey do you know how to Riverdance Gabe
the river down
[Music]
that's great sounds sick
Nick yeah there it is let's see the
river dancing Gabe you know how to do it
you got to keep your arms stiff by your
side and kick the legs you know what I
mean
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know the pixelation
I'm loving it man all right Gabe we're
not getting great reception but I can
tell you're having a good St Patrick's
Day and that's all that matters if you
kill any snakes kill them for me or if
you see any snakes make sure you kill
them for us okay you don't want to get
bitten by snakes hell no not today
brother Gabe Gabe are you are you
smoking a Kuba Kuba cigar that's an acid
Blondie yeah acid yeah that's a flavored
cigars those are strong the the the the
dark ones the strong ones can make you
throw up oh nauseous hell no not on this
day is this your first time trying a
cigar
I smoked cigar several times huh not the
first time
all right Gabe have fun man thanks for
the call uh thanks for calling in nice
to hear from you happy St Patrick's Day
[__]
Baby [__]
Patrick's Day [__] [__] snakes baby
snakes
snakes yeah for real how do we feel
about snakes Gabe
well I wouldn't want to get bitten by
one hell
well said my brother all right happy uh
Happy Luck of the Irish Stadium okay
stay out of trouble all right enjoy God
bless you
foreign
[Applause]
how many snakes has he killed today
that's what I want to know
I've killed 11 snakes today brother
and I wrote them into a different Island
now we're like totally embracing an
island brought up a different colony of
the British killed seven snakes today I
rolled it up because I smoked two snakes
in the morning
Lucky Charms and I smoked two snakes at
night
as if this holiday like
was already making so much sense now
let's just take it even further right
so yeah St Patrick's Day has always been
a bit of a mystery to me to be honest as
a Jewish person too like I got I I got
like most people like yeah I got a
little Irish little nickels and dimes or
whatever I got nothing well a lot a lot
of my friends were like half Irish or
Irish and their parents would like have
the leprechauns be at their house when
they got home from school and I'm like
why don't I get that my mom's like
you're Jewish but they had like somebody
went over dress up no no I like like the
way that Santa will like kind of stop
the kids they would leave like green
Footprints yeah
um but I'm like I want that they're like
no you're Jewish you don't get that
you'll get that yeah you don't get green
Footprints we're not cool you don't get
fun holidays right
well we're here to celebrate and like I
said we've got a whole slew of the most
offensive cocktails we could think of
but first
I'm pretty sure Ela you've never had an
Irish Car Bomb so here's what it is well
aren't we rebranding
no actually I want to call it there is I
think there is like an official like PC
name for it isn't it like Irish blast or
uh smash Irish Slammer Slammer
so people are trying to Rebrand it
because yeah there's carbons
is there another can we even do like a
more offensive name take it the other
direction no that's kind of already as
bad as it gets it's like it'd be hard to
talk it would be hard you'll be hard to
top that right so we
yeah so you said don't attempt so it'll
be too hard so Ela we have a Guinness
beer love okay and then this is um
what is this called what is this
oh it's Bailey's an Irish whiskey it's
Bailey's which is like a you know what
Bailey's is it's like a tasty thing
right it's like alcoholic cream yeah
because they're such degenerate alcohols
they need [__] alcohol in their
coffee creamer
right so you drop it in effect stop I'm
telling everybody I mean come on dude
it's all in the holiday I'm just
celebrating Irish St Patrick's Day
you're not celebrating them by calling
them all degenerate drunks it's a
holiday what the [__] I didn't do it but
apparently it's not they don't even
celebrate it they're actually
leprechauns they're not they're not real
what the Americans are the drunks we're
the drunk DeGeneres yeah okay so you you
drop it in like violently and then you
have to chug it and the thing is it gets
really disgusting if you don't drink it
fast it starts to curdle this is not for
me and when I was a kid I couldn't do it
because I wasn't good at drinking
alcohol I think I'm better at it now
okay so drop it in like this okay
there we go this one's for Bobby Sands
for the Irish I just taste goodness it's
yummy
so you can see how it's curdling
wow
such a foul drink
I think it's great
it's [__] good
[Music]
chug in that I think that's the first
time in my life what the hell I've
actually finished the Irish chug this
whole cup
first time in my life
can I get a towel or something yes
I've come a long way you know I don't
drink alcohol pretty much ever
um somebody was wondering if I should
drink I'm totally fine to drink I am not
pregnant
and I'm like I'm actually in between
because I'm done doing the stuff they
took out the eggs so now I can like ruin
my body real quick and then fix it real
quick you have about two weeks before
you're pregnant
so that's pretty cool that's actually
pretty cool that you know yeah so let's
go hard
you know in college I was thank you I
was not a great drinker and it's kind of
embarrassing in a way like not that I
wanted to go it's embarrassing not that
I wanted to get trashed but like you
don't want to be someone who doesn't
handle their alcohol good I wasn't
puking but I would get super nauseous
that's like stupid pressure to put on
yourself like bro you need to be a good
Drinker I I it is a thing it's so stupid
you don't get any respect I feel like
women don't get that like yeah obviously
we're gonna drink bad and puke and I'll
do all that stuff you know that's like
what all my friends would do well
I think because I had such anxiety in
throughout College my stomach was always
in turmoil so I would drink and it would
always feel super nauseous like even
after one beer
so it's nice to be able to prove to the
world hey friends from college if you're
watching
I can do it [__] you that was very
impressive thank you man I feel like I'm
redeeming myself for all those years of
being a [__] drinker
but also like who cares if you're a [__]
drinker
right but it you wouldn't understand
Neil
I'm here to correct it well a lot of
times I would want to get drunk and hang
out with my friends but I literally
couldn't drink enough alcohol because I
was definitely on a puke like I couldn't
get it down so I'm drunk you know
hey
um actually I remember that
when we first met oh yeah now I'm having
a memory
or like people wanted to do shots and
you're like I can't do it I knew if I
did it okay which sucks because I wanted
to get drunk it was like really hard for
me to get drunk but it's really not a
big deal well I just wanted to have fun
and it was hard because I was
how the [__] are you not drunk I just
I've only had one drinking Stars you
know just started today uh so that was
great I'm actually already feeling that
tingling forcing through my veins
that's a whole Cup on that Irish Buzz
man that was awesome
I can sip on this the cream tastes good
yeah okay good there you go
that was very nice I could I could do
another Irish Car Bomb but we have more
cocktails to try we have other and more
shows to do and more milk yeah we're
only 28 minutes in actually
speaking of which we're almost at break
time good idea let's thank our sponsors
before this gets two out of hand
so after this we'll go back to the
drinking segment but first let's thank
our wonderful glorious beautiful
sponsors
for example honey
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer the only way to
shop it is it's just amazing you guys
just trust me
it's a free extension
it takes two seconds to install it
installs in like two clicks
and it just passively runs as you shop
on the internet and when you're at
checkout
it does a drop down menu it says do you
want me to look for coupons you say yes
and then it goes
boom and then it's like here's a giant
saving that you did not expect every
time
I think we must have saved probably a
thousand dollars by now that's safe just
to assume for sure yeah for sure yeah
yeah so you don't have to worry about
searching for coupon codes that's the
thing of the past you know honey is the
it's free 100 free scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart
are these all mine that I send you then
a lot of these are yours yeah uh the
majority are yours yeah there's some uh
from fans
um but yeah most of these are just ones
you send me this is a she is a shop
women be shopping we do be shopping I
don't do much else you know
no queen I'm saying oh oh new slings
thank you for that really generous
donation says uh this is a donation for
the Uber ride home
[Laughter]
thank you very smart very uh sweet and
thoughtful Tyler says uh looks like
Goblin mode is coming out early boys and
girls we're in the middle of the ad Reed
I know oh my God my mom asked me about
you had a goblin my thumbnail and she
was like did he actually do this costume
I was like no it's Photoshop it was just
a meme yeah and then she was like what
is that Goblin she was trying to read it
don't ask yeah I was like especially you
don't want to know yeah you don't know
about Goblin Ethan you know um honey has
saved us so much money and the amount
and you know the variety of websites it
works on is pretty
pretty awesome I'm talking about pizza
Tech clothing furniture
all different flavors of websites really
you know
you remember what kind of stuff you were
buying that saved you
um there was furniture There was clothes
the furniture ones are crazy I'm saving
like hundreds of dollars look at that
400 bucks down there
it's uh one fetty there were one down
there's 400 dude right that one
oh
yeah hey guess what honey doesn't just
work on desktops now it works on your
iPhone too just activate it on Safari on
your phone and save on the go if you
don't already have honey you will you're
straight up missing out on free money
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting our show
thank you so much get PayPal honey for
free at joinhoney.com after dark that's
joinhoney.com after dark thank you thank
you so much honey we love honey
we love hunting
and finally a big thank you to Native
the deodorant and uh you know
[Music]
products cleaning products that just
work and everybody here loves these
mother lovers
because we like to keep it
all
natural with Native
very fresh feeling legit like I know AB
uses a native you use native yeah I
started using it I use the deodorant now
it's like oh Mom
Mom oh mommy oh Mom
yeah so it's it's pretty awesome uh
Native listen
I love native actually they have a
limited edition candy uh sense what I'm
using gummy bear and the cinnamon toast
or some [__] yeah and it's surprisingly
not like sweet in a bad way it's just a
little like fun fresh
that's why I love natives uh they've got
a limited edition candy shop collection
and you know like all Native products
they're thoughtfully formulated to keep
me feeling and and smelling deliciously
fresh all day long baby native is
aluminum free
you don't want that crap apparently it's
really bad for you the aluminum and the
pores the antiperspirant deodorants they
put aluminum in it to clog your pores
that sounds so bad yeah
and I've heard that it's
oh we don't talk about that come on oh
no I didn't I didn't mention okay thank
you yeah but that's what they say okay
thank you
but they're all natural love that
in fact they're using you know stuff
that you recognize like coconut oil shea
butter baking soda
how's that smelly B
amazing
it's my favorite this is the Lilac and
white tea tasted a little lilac
I'm not gonna taste it
it smells like you could but you
shouldn't right yeah it's not food it's
uh deodorant
we have other sponsors for food
native deodorant checks a lot of boxes
it's 72 hours for your stinky ass
72 hours naturally derived ingredients a
smooth residue-free application I hate
that [__] when it leaves dots in your
armpit so nasty dude
what's the deal with that [__] like
nobody actually used that [__] anymore
do they
uh I don't think so
everyone should be using native yeah
yeah you want light you're full if
you're not literally you're a fool who's
got like one crucial white chunks under
the armpitage I have memories of seeing
that it's so vile it's like what the
hell is that like nuclear grade
deodorant why do you have chunks on your
armpit but natives is much better
when you use native you smell amazing
all day long thanks to their long
lasting scents you could smell spicy
woodsy sweet or clean or fresh they've
got all kinds of different scent options
all different flavors fun and
traditional both
they've got for example from the candy
one gummy bear strawberry vanilla Taffy
sour Berry belt
I personally okay I'm not gonna go there
love it though Brenda's gonna go
something with the sour but I wasn't
going to get there all we gotta do is
read the scrap right
now is the time to make the switch from
an antiperspirant to Native when you
visit their site you can discover all
the fresh scents and maybe even try one
of their body washes while you're at it
yeah it's awesome you guys should really
do me a favor go to the link go to the
website just check it out see if any of
the uh scents
sound interesting or nice to you give it
a shot just try it you're gonna love it
right now go to nativdeo.com after dark
or use the promo code after dark at
checkout to get a sweet 20 off your
first order that's native I know it's
crazy that's a lot
that's
nativedeo.com after dark or use promo
code after dark at checkout for 20 off
your first order thank you native I love
you and please support our sponsors
thank you
I love that song man clapping same this
is a new one right Zach
new one for the road time dude love it
yeah all right so back to uh uh two
speeds fun fact about normalizing
oppression the idiom Beyond The Pale is
a reference to the areas of Irish
self-rule outside the English pale from
when the English were colonizing Ireland
it equates Irish people governing
themselves with outrageous behavior
Beyond The Pale I never wow wow that is
that's really interesting yeah watching
a wiena it's like the Savages Beyond The
Pale
there's a lot of expressions like that
that it's just super common and you
never even think about it you look into
the origin like oh my God yeah I'm still
trying to unpack the
pack so so when England was colonizing
Ireland yeah so beyond the pale
references an area where the Irish ruled
themselves outside of the English area
the pale being the English so they're
like the Savages so yeah especially
Beyond The Pale means it's just like
unimaginably horrible yeah you've gone
too far
very interesting little bit of trivia
there thank you yeah and lesson it's
quite funny too because we were talking
about this term [__] and how that's super
[__] up and all of us know yeah
oh God Mouse I said five gifted thank
you says Ethan here you go finish
another drink turn up oh JJ what are you
doing it's Friday baby AJ what are you
doing to me you know um the term gypped
I still hear like regularly and I don't
know I don't know yeah I think most
people are just ignorant yeah I don't
know what the correct thing to do one
time I was like you know I don't think
you're supposed to say that and she was
like really you say Gypsy stands for
gyps from Gypsy yeah so yeah Whoopi
Goldberg said it the other day and she
had apologize for it yeah oh wow
yeah an old timey moment whoopsy Daisy
so it's like things are catching up you
know we started with like restarted
that's a big one it's obvious and then
we're working our way down to like the
uh
more obscure offensive yeah yeah right
right we're working our way through the
uh colloquials here in the English
language yeah thank you uh moose eyes
for five gifted subbies
go
[__] love that oh by the way we are
finishing up Dan the producer origin
story lore for tomorrow who is Dan the
producer
where did he come from yeah we've never
imagined I would have an origin story
he came from Heaven well one of the
clips we were joking about how we should
have a montage because you'd only been
there for two months right you were like
passing Dan montage
we actually do have a Dan Montage now
it's been a long time
honestly
it's so fun to go through and look for
all the all the old clips especially
with crew members
so crazy we have like history now it's
kind of yeah
it's really wild
so we did the Irish Car Bomb so here
we're going to invent a couple of our
drinks now okay
I liked that drink I gotta say and that
was I didn't it's a good one yeah I did
enjoy that so are you ready for uh the
number two drink Sam
and this is doesn't offend the whole
nation but it does defend one person
and they do say uh to save one man is to
save the world
in this case
we're killing one man everybody says
that the world yeah it's like a Jewish
saying isn't it uh save
to save one person is to save the whole
I don't know save one person save the
world
Someone Saved Me are you quoting are you
quoting the television show Heroes no
no save the cheerleaders save the world
coming to mind listen bro
I got it it's a Jew it's a um
it's a Jewish tradition it's a the
saying is whoever Saves a Life Saves the
World okay
yeah actually no thank you so much Sam
that looks that looks really nice save
one life save the entire world
no whoever said [__] there was like a
more poetic way to say it
whoever saves me yeah
it was in Schindler's List
yeah Dan what I was being anti-semitic I
already admitted it I apologize you
gotta make a drink
yeah so so you go
so we're doing the inverse of that okay
so you want to tell us about our
cocktail here the sneak of cocktail Sam
uh it is some Pina Colada mix coconut
puree and a shot of rum wow okay but
Ethan I'm sorry but you're not allowed
to eat or you're not allowed to drink
that at the table
I'm gonna have to ask you to step off
okay sure yeah so it is okay Ela you go
right ahead you get to stay yep hell
yeah what's with the cover that's your
seedless you just put this here oh yeah
you're coming it's not part of the bed
you could give them part of the
experience you could like Splash it a
little bit or something
that's horrible so we drink
there seems to be white chunks floating
in this huh the coconut puree yeah it
looks like semen a little bit
jacket off ew why'd you say that I think
it's supposed to right Sam
she's not here at the moment copy that
just drink it I see oh I got it it's
foul strong it is strong what's in this
again
milk you know what's in there
gotcha Pina Colada mix
coconut puree how much rum is in here
girl coming
in white rum
this is a tough one it's hard to swallow
I know it's hard
I had one look at Ila I had ELO took
three soups sips and I had to leave the
room
laughs
Eli can you do something like this like
yeah I want to [__] drink the [__]
out of this drink
can you do like that
like you're cooking me make love to the
cocktail
you did not prepare me for this yeah
you're you didn't you missed the snake
maybe oh it's nice sorry
this is horror I don't know we're
supposed to get some heads up yeah I
usually prepula on the segments but not
this one
I love this drink oh my God
it is so strong though this is really
hard
say something like
say something like get the [__] over
here cocktail but that talk put that
cocktail in me say like that
we needed to be one more drink in for me
to be that way you don't have to you
don't have to emote just say get that
cocktail in me
you can do that
[Laughter]
[Music]
yo guys so I went to this motel with my
girl and we were drinking this cocktail
okay and listen I knew we were going
there to drink right I knew that but I
don't like alcohol that much I thought
we'd be smoking weed and I saw her
drinking that cocktail and she just
loved it way more than I expected she
would I was there to get high but she
got trashed and I it was making me very
uncomfortable bro I didn't know what I
got myself into
oh yeah
let me get that cocktail in me
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he did this to himself you know well now
you can tell him you sympathize right I
know how it feels
Sam
I want to tell you with peace and love
this is the worst drink I've ever had
I think that's the intent it's supposed
to be strong tough to swallow yeah right
literally another type of milk dude it
is so wild dude really
I don't mind no it's not that violence
strong okay wait
was all of ours mixed together yeah it's
all one big vat is that right Sam or did
you mix it in each drink separately oh
no there was I made two batches and I
mixed it up in big jars because this is
like straight rum with like chunks of
Jizz In It Well I noticed when I when I
poured it it started separating the rum
was coming to the top and the puree was
kind of sinking so well that's good
because that's what happens when you put
juice in water
like solidifies that's what clogs drains
people yeah we love that we love that
hold on Dan if you love this you got to
taste this because okay I just want to
see if this is what you're doing I feel
like it's not a bad drink it's just
strong
but I don't know maybe yours is
different
Dan is trying it he just took a sip oh
you're right that was way more
Ethan is Right Ethan's is way stronger
so they are swapping
Ethan is taking dance crank
Ethan is going back to the room
Ethan wasn't [__] his uh open Taste
of coconut was just all rum
this one actually looks way more coming
oh my God Sam you're like a mad
scientist this is a calm cocktail Can it
can you guys get close over this this is
just straight up
I mean mine mine looks pretty nasty too
I don't know no I know I know sneako's
into this kind of thing but like for
them to come and jizz in my drink that's
going too far cheers
oh there you go okay nice and chunky
yeah dip your finger in it oh I don't
like this one it's thick all right well
now I really feel like I'm drinking [__]
good protein maybe this is not your
drink
well you know what do you not like
coconut
okay okay
this is like pina colada technically you
know what it isn't my drink and that's
why I don't go to uh these kinds of
Clubs
right
not that there's anything wrong with it
but if you know you're not into it don't
go
right right
okay well shout out to
um snico there's some creative ideas to
celebrate since Patrick's Day for you
cheers
Cheers Cheers
[Music]
up next Sam you ready for the next one
or you want us to talk she's on her way
she says okay great
so the third drink we have is called the
trono tree no Chernobyl meltdown
which
is offensive
I mean that was a giant disaster and it
ruined the lives of many it just
desecrated like a whole geographical
location that's uninhabitable right
you know what we saw uh just the other
day was um I think when we were talking
about this was it was it just bottled
water or was it oh it's not it was vodka
there's vodka made from the water
internal hell yeah
what's the name did you find it again
yeah
wait
wait for real yeah apparently and is it
Radioactive I mean I have to imagine the
whole point was to show that it's it's
better there now
I I don't think the appeal is that it is
radioactive is it gonna I don't know
okay so here it is as you can see we've
got the red punch and a radioactive kind
of uh I love this cup you know what I'm
talking about right
Sam did you make this or was this cup
[Music]
oh that's kind of dope it's like a
glow-in-the-dark ring
oh for the radiation very cool very
radiating this actually could be a drink
I haven't tried it yet but
damn what's in this one
uh she's still uh grabbing the smells
good she's running over that one is I
put the bottle on the desk but it's
something that I just found called
lemonade oh that's nice
there's a little bit of uh Cherry
Mountain Dew and a shot of vodka okay oh
okay good cheers to the Chernobyl
meltdown
to call it chevala
[Music]
or some something
um
no that's my kind of drink
I can barely taste the Vodka such a such
a tragedy to be honest
do you watch the miniseries yeah good
right
chernobyla dude I watched it
and I was blown and it scared the [__]
out of me yeah
it's pretty scary
level yeah what what about it did did it
scare you baby just that it was based
off a true story and just like I'm able
to immerse myself so deeply whenever I
smoke watching something oh yeah and uh
well it was very scary at the time yeah
something like that could happen it's
pretty scary yeah that I swear to God
probably the one of the tensest scenes
ever shot is that scene where they have
to go on the roof and shovel off on the
radioactive yeah and they can only be
out there for like 30 seconds yeah and
it's like it's just dudes with shovels
lifting stuff and it was like scarier
than almost anything I've ever seen it's
like unbelievable it's one of my
favorite miniseries yeah so yeah right
probably even scary in real life to be
honest like probably definitely I mean
it's like yeah I've seen people
literally die you know well how would
they get sick yes so what was really
interesting was first how they it blew
up and all the people are like watching
it from the bridge they all died yeah
right
and then also there was people that went
to the power plant to like inspect the
rubble and they were picking up like
pieces of your of uh uranium the
graphite they died yeah the graphite
yeah and they had to like bury them in
like uh I forget what kind of coffins
they were they were like probably yeah
yeah [__] up but you know even now if
you look at Chernobyl that's got like
this huge [__] Iron Dome over it that
and they're gonna need to replace it too
like every yep 50 or 60 years this is
what it looks like now oh it's kind of
scary right now when Russia is like
bombing [__] near it exactly like we're
risking to like re like basically
shivola to Ebola too
vivola too the Electric Boogaloo yeah
yeah it's crazy like how how close we're
actually actually to to another uh yeah
the guy who wrote the Chernobyl show he
also did Last of Us
yeah but he also wrote scary movie three
scary movie four and The Hangover Part
Two and part three this dude had the
biggest [__] turnaround in his career
of all time from like the schlocky [__]
to like Prestige like top tier
television yeah what a uh what a resume
yeah what a breath of work just goes to
show you know what's in people this man
is just casually walking by the biggest
nuclear catastrophe in man's history
with a backpack there's a tick tock page
of this girl that goes there it's called
Chernobyl Diaries or something like that
and she just walks around and she's like
see I'm fine everything's fine here
I think you know outside of uh what do
they call it the not the catacomb the um
what's the name for the confinement the
coffin maybe they call it yeah it is
sarcophagus there you go yeah uh I think
outside of there at this point it's you
know relatively low radiation the thing
is like I guess all the uh radiated soil
has now been like buried over but if
they start bombing the area then it will
kick up all the radioactive soil again
and then it will become really dangerous
didn't we watch that guy who was like
splashing through the water there yeah
we did watch right love him that was
awesome rap tournament pad radish head
yeah radish that was [__] awesome
yeah you know the saddest part about
that show for me was when they had to go
kill the dogs
it's brutal yeah you know in Sweden my
dad tells me that they weren't allowed
to eat berries uh for like a year after
because like the radiation came in
nobody really yeah for like a couple
years after no [__] berries bro it
was advised to not to yeah there was a
scene where all the uh they had to kill
all the wildlife in the area because
they were radioactive yeah and uh all
the people had
evacuated leaving in many cases their
family dogs behind and they had to go
through the village just hunting down
all these uh poor doggies and shooting
them
[__] horrific
wow is this the same one
oh we ran out of uh lemonade apparently
that one looked even more radioactive so
I'm like I guess that's true it's so
good the time with the lemonade is
pretty good just yeah on the meme level
but
you're right this is but there it is the
Chernobyl uh the nuclear fallout
cocktail we love that
and this has this has vodka in it or
some something but you know it's a shame
that a nuclear energy gets such a bad
rep because
obviously there's been some really bad
disasters or Chernobyl and then recently
from the earthquake in Japan but well
regular legged nuclear reactors are very
safe and also could basically
solve all of our energy problems and
their completely clean energy there's no
emissions yeah
there's no missions there's waste but
well nuclear waste is no you're right
though on the whole it's one like for
the scale of uh Power that we need to
make up for from coal and stuff nuclear
is like the only we're not there with
the solar and wind yet to Fusion's
almost there from what I understand
well there was that big news about it
recently yeah but I don't know I'm not
that might still be another 20 years
away nuclear is actually the largest
source of clean power in the United
States I don't know did you know nuclear
is considered clean power no yeah it's
it's really it's really a shame because
it's such a phenomenal source of energy
but I guess it's like so could be so
dangerous
so well it yeah it could but like I
think if they're made correctly right
they're not dangerous you know what I
mean there needs to be like the correct
uh safety measures in place I believe an
individual citizen in this country has a
writing a nuclear warhead right and if
we had more nuclear plants we'd have
more uranium to give out to citizens to
make their own nuclear bombs and what is
Fusion
so Fusion is
what the Sun uses to fuel itself okay
and what that means is
you split at hydrogen atom which is
essentially like just water
uh that's vision of fission fusion is
when you combine two atoms to get power
most all nuclear power plants that exist
currently are fission plants where you
split atoms okay so few so Fusion
is Fusion is theoretically like super
safe and super clean but um they've been
trying to make it happen for like a
hundred years and really only what it
was like six months ago that they
finally had a breakthrough where they
were able to get a little bit of power
out of it so in the next couple decades
they might be able to figure it out it's
when uh I guess yeah when they when they
fuse together
they let off energy the problem is is
that it's always been a paradox because
you have to put so much energy in to
start the reaction we've never been able
to
create a situation where more energy
comes out than we put in and what makes
it so safe is that once the energy cuts
the fusion stops
whereas with nuclear power as we have it
today if the energy goes off then you
have a meltdown it runs out because how
it works is we're constantly cooling it
down with water and stuff to keep it
from exploding
and so when you lose electricity which
is what happened I think
you know in the case of Chernobyl or it
happened actually recently in Ukraine
again where they cut off the power to a
nuclear power plant there Russia did
then then it will go uh
it will have a meltdown wow so so by
Nature fission is very safe
and it's also I think really
the fuel is just like water isn't it
it's like it's nothing crazy at all
so the way that they're working on it
now is they have like
hundreds of tiny lasers like super high
energy lasers like shooting at one tiny
tiny spot to try to create a fission
reaction
that's like the uh Holy Grail of power
if we can figure that out first
what was that Jimmy flavors
someone in chat said alcohol makes Ethan
super smart
wait you said flavors or lasers
well what is the difference huh flavors
I said lasers but flavors what wait
wait tell us muted uh everybody's making
fun of how I say uh nuclear in the and
like oh yeah I say I like Bush I know I
know it's wrong but how'd you say it
nuclear nuclear oh it's nuclear okay
I'll be honest I
sweating
I don't really [__] hear the
difference that much really new killer
there's like an extra the way I say it
has like very different syllable that
doesn't really need to be there nuclear
nuclear nuclear nuclear
it's very similar it's nuclear I'm
saying it right I'm saying you're right
nuclear new nuclear yeah nuclear yeah
two syllables new nuclear clear
that's supposed to be mentioned nuclear
yeah I think you guys may be drunk
you're drunk and I said y'all may be
drunk just by proxy dance
[Music]
step in Cheers Cheers
you know we're [__] when I'm the only
sober one
this should actually mean I should give
you the button I'm getting my
authorization no I'm okay
transferring command to a b Dan tried to
give me a button I'm like no it's okay
nuclear codes I'm gonna give it to Ian I
got a button
just scream if you want me to slam it
just scream go ah button
so um it's pretty but yeah what's really
exciting is that we've been trying to
figure out fission for a long time
Fusion Vision Vision Fusion no fusion
and there was recently a huge
breakthrough where they were able to sh
to um get more energy out than they put
in for the first time the fission only
lasted for a split second but yeah
when do you learn about this stuff and
how how do I do it yeah because I see
what you're watch you're watching the
same shows as me
So I listened to like news podcasts and
stuff I'm in the car and I read stuff
online and
um read it a lot of times it was a
pretty big it was it was all over the
news when it when it first happened it
was uh actually no one of the housewives
was talking about
yeah Jane Shaw was talking about it in
Salt Lake City someone in the chat Ethan
could you give us like a quick rundown
on string theory
yeah I could so yeah explain to me
streak theory is the theory
that string theory was invented is that
the one about the universe being like
it's all vibrations it's all Vibes dude
that's not what I thought well so that
it was created to unify the theory
of uh relativity with the world of the
um subatomic
so as we understand huge bodies of mass
work yeah they completely follow the
laws of physics as we know it and
relativity but when you get down to a
tiny subatomic level the rules
completely change right and so people
they call it the Theory of Everything
quote unquote they're trying to find out
how do we think of a mathematical theory
that explains both of these things
because when you take one Theory and
apply it to one it makes no sense
and so that's what String Theory
attempts to do
is where they say that the foundation of
the universe is based on vibrations and
strings and it's all very theoretical
it's all it's all very very theoretical
kind of wild [__] the strength there
science is gay but that's that's yeah
what is gay
science is gay
size gay size
science oh science is science is gay I'm
not gay shut up yeah
we need Super String Theory dude
super String Theory yeah that's an
actual thing it is a thing I know super
string theory is to explain quantum
gravity in
I don't know that's about all I know
super String Theory I actually I don't
know how to define that one did you not
like masturbate for a week or something
you became super smart
dude when he stops like doing it he
becomes a genius
you know I know about it no but actually
Ethan is always like that I'm always I'm
always surprised because it's like what
where did that come from
and I know about dark matter is that
related to what you just explained
because like they don't know what it is
well Dark Matter factors in age 14. dark
matter is uh
uh is takes place in the world of
physics
it's matter that doesn't interact with
light so it's not related at all so
there's like a huge amount of the only
way that the expansion of the universe
as we observe it makes sense
mathematically
is if there's a thing called Dark Matter
tickle matter which actually represents
like 60 of all matter in the universe
eighty percent if you don't know what I
don't know what the [__] it is I've
heard about that
we've been able to detect it because it
Crea it has gravity it can bend light
so when we look into space we can see
that there is dark matter because it
bends the light but the light but it
doesn't pass through doesn't interact
with the dark matter
that interesting it is how do you know
all this and then you still can't
pronounce magnum opus
[Laughter]
It's A Beautiful Mind
thank you
yeah your brother's like really smart
too isn't he yeah yeah he's super and
it's really funny when they all start
it's a nightmare talking about something
and everybody thinks they know the
answer I was yeah when I was at your
guys's house last time I forget what it
was for but I was hearing them talk like
holy [__] I have no idea what the hell
they're talking about but I was
impressed the thing about John is that
sometimes he is right and sometimes he's
wrong but he speaks like he's right
hallway I got sometimes and sometimes
like I even know that he's wrong and I
don't consider myself like smart smart
like but he has nothing up here he has
no humility no fight to them it will
fight and I'm like Sean you're wrong
somebody asked can you talk about the um
the Multiverse and actually I can I find
that also very interesting okay I don't
know about the Multiverse
so theoretically
we live in a contained Universe okay we
don't know how big the universe is we
don't know if it's infinite or finite
all we know is that
space time
which is the fabric of the universe is
expanding faster than life in travel
but the consensus among scientists today
is that the universe is actually finite
really it's not infinite oh it's not
that border it ends somewhere it does
end somewhere it's constantly expanding
but it is a finite space so the question
begs what's outside of that right
so the Multiverse suggests that
[Laughter]
muted I
expected this episode ago I'm happy with
it it's going great
astrophysics
this is great can I get it Sarah is
saying I'm too high for this okay so
what the Multiverse suggests in theory
it takes drinks and acts like he's high
is that um
outside the border of our universe yeah
and other parts of reality other
universes came to be got it that makes
sense and in other universes the laws of
physics are completely different which
is hard to imagine but you know what's
what's interesting is I like to think
about like this
we think about the universe the chance
for life we say there's got to be other
life because there's so many planets
there's so many stars
if you have you know a billion stars
what's the chance that there's not like
10 life forms there right and so
what's possible
is what if there's a trillion different
universes
and it's only in 10 of them
where the laws of physics allow for
matter to exist at all so so yeah I
gotcha so it would be in a completely
totally different Universe it's like you
couldn't even conceive of it because the
laws of physics we take we take it for
granted that it's like some
just uh normal way of living but it's
not yeah every time we start talking
about things like that I feel like my
brain is just gonna crash like a
computer that's just like not well it's
all very theoretical it's all kind of
just thought experiments you know thank
you for the gifted smug but also so
another suggestion with the Multiverse
is that
if reality if reality
is infinite the space of reality is
infinite
what do you want Lily things
I've just been listening if the space of
reality is infinity yeah that suggests
that there's infinite multiverses
infinite in reality and so what that
suggests is that anything that can
happen
will happen
some Multiverse
of our reality
a lot of people mistake that they say
anything guys everything will happen
that's not what it means like there's
not going to be a universe where I just
randomly punch you in the face for no
reason right now I'd go oh punch you in
the face
it's not anything can happen it's
anything that can happen will happen so
it's like I come to a decision I say I'm
going to stay in LA or I'm going to go
to Israel but in another Multiverse I
make the other decision I think if it's
truly infinite infinite then there is a
real there is definitely at least one
reality where you stalk you in the face
no no that's not what it means it has to
be a possibility it has to be but why is
it not a possibility because he's just
he's trying to say
so much because it's out of character
yeah yeah it's silly it's not a good
theory it's not a good thought
appearance to be like oh well all of a
sudden I lived all the way up to my life
now and then I go they check his [__] on
the floor and then eat it there's a
really well that's what happens maybe my
friend maybe in this universe but there
may be another version of you
like a Toby McGuire version it's
anything that can happen can happen that
can't happen it can't it's physically
possible for you to [__] on floor and
that's the branching universe theory a b
where possibilities Branch off and then
each different decision represents a
whole that's totally like a movie I feel
like that already exists at once yeah it
just it literally just won best picture
last weekend so wait which year
everything everywhere well I love that
movie by the way
I love it oh it's so good
it was one of the most unique unique
movies I think yeah I loved it
explaining it to Lena's mom was a
nightmare but
I loved watching Ela watch it uh that
was so funny oh yeah he watched me
holding my phone I think right it was on
my phone was that one oh was it you're
right it was on your phone well that was
sad viewing very sad looked great though
we still enjoyed the movie well the
first time I heard about branching uh
universes was actually
um Back to the Future oh yes the
branching universes where Biff becomes
the billionaire no somebody asked Can
you ex can you explain the metaverse
the metaverse yeah we have a series of
episodes
that explain it in great detail actually
that's one thing I do not get at all the
universe is a mystery to me can you
explain the flux capacitor and how that
makes time travel yeah
you know what I would want to talk about
I cannot then you um telescope that like
James Webb yeah I got a piece so bad
okay
can I get another shot in this it's like
too sweet you want the AC on it was cold
so we turned it I'm so hot okay I need
AC
res the biggest trick in the
night uh Amazon show yeah yeah we got it
we got it we got it yeah we Gotti happy
St Patrick's Day everybody
[Music]
I hope you're all having a beautiful St
Patrick's Day we're all drinking oh
drinking I'm gonna have about 13 or 14
drinks in me at the end of the day top
of the morning
say something real quick because St
Patrick's you gotta say in an Irish
accent Zach
zombie zombie
um
it's actually that's not how the song
goes at all
there you go okay
this weekend this weekend
yeah you go to dance then you come to
mine this weekend's like ten dollars
we'll be playing musical chairs
hi guys uh welcome to the history can I
please say what I wanted everyone is
drunk and me please God damn it let me
say shaky person is in control we have
to go to the bathroom
how many bathrooms do you guys have uh
two check check
some cover for Olivia okay I'm in a
beast chair right now oh you're covering
for Abby let me go to Olivia's real
quick okay
drinking right now what the [__] yeah
hold on this is everything everywhere at
once I'm sorry about this everyone we're
just stay still hold on Happy St
Patrick's Day everybody
you can stay in your chair you're good
yeah you're perfect there oh okay okay
well your chair is too high me
I don't like it
Sam where are you Lena can you go to my
chair real quick
bro what the [__] is happening
it's weird
[Music]
is live with the rocks in May 13th ten
dollars off this weekend ten dollars off
oh there we go okay next week is the
holy month of Ramadan shout out to
everybody who will be shut up
Shut Up cheer hey Cheers Cheers
[Laughter]
shout out Ramadan
shout out shout out
shout out everyone who's going to shout
out to their family go ahead Lena what
were you saying what'd you say say it
again
shout out to everyone who's observing
Ramadan is it Ramadan right now not yet
next week special shout out to Allah you
said who's observing Ramadan right now
that would mean they were
their calendar was all [__] up
well shout out to them now shout out to
those who will be serving
right here's a shot of vodka with food
coloring
oh so it doesn't taint the waters real
quick Olivia I I have to Could you um
yeah come switch
[Laughter]
let's go can I say something it's easy
you'll figure it out
there
Olivia Olivia switch
es oh God
I'm trying to find myself I had one
there she is
wait and back to Ethan and Nila
yeah nice can I say something you're a
natural as I was coming back from the
bathroom yeah I heard it Ian said I have
to pee so bad he said it to Olivia and I
heard it
I got a piece so bad
[Laughter]
you're doing great Olivia this is like
when I was switching thanks guys thank
you thank you I'm having so much fun
thank you
okay yes yes yes
F9 F9
just wanted to tell you guys that I'm
stepping away and Ethan is Ethan yeah
that's Ian great job great good job
Olivia yeah so um
Adrian asked can Ethan help me with my
plasma Dynamics research proposal I
don't know anything about that I'm sorry
about that plasma is the fourth uh state
of matter
what they call like blood plasma because
I know that's not like a mystery I think
that's irrelevant wait is that like new
stuff
plasma no I don't think so it's kind of
old oh okay yeah but whenever I hear
plasma I think of like sci-fi like
plasma blaster
I think of that girl that used to turn
into water that show
the girls turned into water
what was that show a girl yeah turned
into water it almost like plasma
anything because I don't know if it was
actually water the shape of water no
it's not a movie yeah it was a TV
a TV show The Wonder Twins someone in
chat will know it's like a girl like
real life like a girl The Secret World
of Alex Mack yeah so that sounds about
right I just Googled TV show where girl
turns into water and that's what came up
I don't know [__] no man Olivia are you
dead though
that sounds kind of right I'm also a
little tipsy right now it's about right
uh anyway did you guys will end up
watching that Elvis movie Alex Mack yeah
I think that's right I'm boycotting it
oh why would you want to do that exactly
the impersonation of Tom hanks's
character well Adrian says plasma is
what powers
[Music]
news to me
thank you though okay I'm back so let's
move on yeah thank you uh welcome back
then so let's move on to our next drink
uh huh you guys never watched that wait
I think that was it
oh there's one more oh wonderful yeah
all right Sam did you lower my seat
enough or
[Laughter]
so the next one up is the Pearl Harbor
Fireball
[Laughter]
which of course commemorates
the bombing of Pearl Harbor at the hands
of the Japanese Army
and World War II bombing oh my God an
absolutely tragic tragic uh event in
American history
work in it whoa okay nice we got wings
and fit
so yes of course uh I feel like this is
a good comparable one to the car bomb
the harbor bomb the herbalber the Pearl
Harbor Fireball Herb Alpert Earl Barber
I think this is inappropriate analogy so
what do we have here Sam we've got the
blue ocean clearly yeah and the red
Flames dropping in a nice analogy it is
a passion fruit white claw that's the
ocean and then there's a shot of vodka
I love it do we have extra
armies
yes I'll bring them dude those are
massive where do you get a gummy that
size
uh maybe the liquid makes it look big I
think Ralph's I think it is Big Ralph's
shout out to Ralph are you guys ready
real baby shark in here who's ready to
start World War II baby wake that
sleeping giant wait who's ready to wait
oh that'd be a good name for it waking
this waking the sleeping giant stop
dissing the Nazis is anyone else been on
this uh I think she's making some more
but you can you can go ahead all right
ready Ela yeah cheers uh uh two we all
know what happened after this
oh it turns purple how cool
because blue and color theories blood in
the water
yeah I'm not good the USS Arizona hey to
the Arizona
oh they are big
shout out to Pearl shout out to Pearl
shout out toon [__] shout out to Pearl
the whale shout out to Pearl the whale
man miss you tune [__] sorry I was so
mean and left the theater when I saw you
that one's pretty wild I can't lie about
it really
drinkable I think it's great
oh my God gummy I don't know if I can
taste anymore it's not chocolate not a
fan of this one no offense has to be one
of those I haven't had the passion fruit
white claw so it's not good some some of
you have Tangerine but so the uh the
passion fruit white Claw is just blue on
its own no it's oh okay the power of
food coloring
[Music]
this should taste like war crimes dude
that's the best flavor of all
you ever seen the movie Tora Tora Tora
is that the one where they blow up but
it's a it's a World War II it's about
Pearl Harbor
it's like an older I think it's
was it 70 1970 who won
uh the Japanese did oh no they won that
round
well anyway you know there's a lot more
offensive drinks frankly and Cocktails
we wanted to make I'm sure but uh
instead of physically making them we
theoretically made them right okay
fun uh yeah I guess I just we all
brainstormed some other peacock auctions
to make it home if you feel like it so
here is uh some of the other ones we
dreamed up but didn't get the chance to
make of course the Irish car bomb as we
did yeah there's some there's some
repeats yeah he has ones for for the
ones that we made Pearl Harbor Fireball
the gum one we just did of course
the original thought was to have uh to
light the shot like how they do
um but uh that's a fire hazard or a
bunch of drunk people yeah
I see the thing is with the shots you
light on fire if you don't put it out
before you drink it which a lot of
people don't know to do you will light
yourself on fire oh yeah I don't I
wouldn't want to play with that know
I've never done it me neither yeah
there's like chunks of the gummy
floating I'm not sure I'm crazy about
that
this one is the altar boy holy water
which is a strong wine served in a juice
box sippy cup
I love that wow
and it's got Pope Benedict the Sith
the greatest ever cover it up
the greatest one that ever covered it up
Amen brother the Chernobyl meltdown
which we tried ourselves it was
concocted of course in the uh I think
that was my favorite the trino yeah that
one's legitimately good and also the cup
helped sell it it's just so fun Saddam
sangria
it's a regular sangria served ice cold
in a poorly ventilated hot bump look how
much he loves it
yeah she smiles see he's having fun
is that actually him yeah I caught him
no this this morning
Coke and Cosby
I'll let you do the math on that one I'm
not an alcoholic but it's a it's a so
this one doesn't have alcohol in it
right it's a different kind of cocktail
but you still somehow get really I don't
know
I love the picture
[Laughter]
I'm America's dad in our religion we
believe the Antichrist has one eye
oh is that right one eye well he's gonna
yeah he's gonna be covering it though so
what can I ask you does he have one
blind eye and one good eye or is he like
a try he's like a cyclops I think he's a
cyclops Lina do you know no I don't know
let me Google it so I would just say
Muslim anti well it's not the Antichrist
because I don't believe him wait yeah
yeah we believe in Christ they believe
in Christ We Believe Christ is a prophet
so Muslim Antichrist
would all still be Antichrist that's
actually
if you look it up yeah it's uh
what's his name Lino
[__] that guy what's his name which one
the Antichrist what's his name [__] that
guy Ethan Klein the one who's gonna go
against Imam Matthew what's his name uh
literally [__] that guy I didn't know he
has a name I bet you somebody in this
you know what's so funny is that my
family is half white and I didn't learn
any of the cool stuff I didn't learn how
to speak Arabic or anything all I got
was this scary [__] from my dead side
yeah the scary religious stuff that's
the best part of religion so yeah
yeah so I look forward to a Coke and
Cosby I could go for one of those
scenario if you know what I mean right
you give it to me
I have your way with me
the Kennedy's Brain Blast
Four Loko
Twist of lime bullet shaped ice cubes
that's great
another good Irish Catholic Honor on
this day right
that's a really clever thing the bullet
ice cubes I love that of course Kennedy
[Music]
we're over that we can make fun of it
we're at bozo it's been long enough
the uh drazden drop of course is a the
lemon drop's a popular drink Corinthian
of course was a fire bombs
German City fire bombed
during World War II
the date the drazden drop
we've got the sneako cocktail which of
course we
knocked it out for you mm-hmm
what the [__] is that photo
where'd you get that cam I just Googled
sneako screaming and that came out
really yeah wow there's a few that's one
of the more dramatic ones but there's a
few
oh he's the false Messiah okay let me
get a picture of this guy his name is
dajal
is that his name is that how it's
pronounced I'm not sure how it's
pronounced honestly
um but yeah chat new chat was sending
you through yeah so he has one bad eye
and one good eye
according to what I'm seeing
yeah
similar to the Antichrist it's like a
cloud like Bill Cosby huh it's it's it's
kind of insane it's kind of cool it's
supposed to be like this Great War it's
gonna be like Affinity war and everyone
like and then like it's supposed to be
led by someone calling my methi and then
like Jesus can be like methi on your
left all the prophets are gonna come
back we got them all we got Moses in
there even though the Buddha shows up
too why not why does he look kind of
cool though he looks he looks like it
looks like a SoundCloud rapper he does
666 on his vow on his hood that's hard
as [__]
[__] he looks like me when I get face
tattoos eventually y'all know my address
it's 666. oh Chad's [__] up they're
calling him Jeff
okay
uh moving on we've got the Helen Keller
colada
I'm not gonna lie what's that Dan I'm
ditching the Pearl Harbor it's the it's
not good no it's actually not good I
could go for another all the others were
hits all the others were hits oh yeah
can we go back to the first one do we
have more car bombs I do do you want one
do you both want one yeah
after that next one boy
that's a juice dude
those are good
you God bless the Irish man
that's right uh yeah what's up
should I come over to your seat you
don't have to but I mean if you want I
can when you have something to put one
in like a bag do you want me to switch
again we'll definitely forgot no but I
could just switch with you if you want
no that's okay thank you so much thank
you
um Helen Keller colada of course it's
just an empty glass because that dumb
that dummy can't see [__]
[Laughter]
you can't hear it just
just dumb and useless
poor anything that feels like it has
liquid in it anywhere you think might
have a class underneath
no she's a fraud she could hear and Sue
trust me if she existed at all she
poured the drink like that on purpose
it's her stick she's like right you know
you you go to the restaurant and there's
these people that go around passing out
cars being like hey I'm I'm deaf and I'm
mute I need you to donate to me they
pass up cards right
that's Helen Keller I must be going to
the wrong restaurants I just got little
kids trying to sell me chocolate bars
for the basketball team maybe that's a
man going to the back of the kitchen
papers it could be an Israel thing
there's people that would come up and
hand you a card that says hey I'm dead
I'm black death oh yeah
yeah they definitely do that
that's her
I know you could pour that [__] in the
glass you just don't want to work
because you're lazy
Welfare Queen Helen Keller oh it feels
like red shut up
feels like thank you Dan feels like you
don't have to work her party trick is
pouring it over there
not in the cup over there
I support it I like the chaos so there
it is uh that there's our drinks thank
you there it is make it at home let us
know what you think yeah which ones are
your favorites let us know at home don't
let your house on fire
so what are we are we going to order
pizza is that the thing or no no okay
literally not that's one can we say that
I thought I heard people talking about
it
nobody
so Mrs crew can you help me decide where
I want to eat lunch Subway talk about or
Culver's or DQ what's Culver's
go to Taco Bell
Subway is uh Jared so we don't have it's
St Patrick's Day you should get some
good Irish food like McDonald's
McDonald's McDonald's
Culver's is a fast food it's like uh
sort of like a jack-in-the-box the
biggest drink in the night of the year
hey you know what how short Jimmy Lee
made a tick tock
in central uh in Times Square okay
or no no sorry this guy there's like
these [__] tier tick Tuckers who just
harass people
and this guy found Jimmy Lee in Times
Square oh my gosh just totally randomly
and he got his ass I know bro Jimmy's
the man look at that Airline brother
Jimmy was out there creating fomo with
his camera crew and they happen to
stumble into this guy wow and this guy I
don't think he's used to running into
people like Jimmy because Jimmy out
trolled him it's amazing he's not ready
for the energy that Jimmy brings here it
is check this out or it is too short and
a guy
5 11. huh five eleven how tall you
shakes three
wonderful the Hat's five inches
411. wonderful
what else okay so look I'ma shoot my
shot like um Devin Booker can I buy his
Presley in the house with Tiny Tim New
York City
[Laughter]
trying to do something strange for a
piece of change because there's
something about chicken and there it is
all right nice to meet you you're the
last guy okay this dude is not on here
oh my God nice try kid calling that guy
Tiny Tim
unironically the funniest thing that
Jimmy Lee's ever said he's so [__]
accurate
but it's so old it's a very old time bro
I thought that was A Christmas Carol
thing Tiny Tim's like the beggar boy
oh you're thinking of from uh from A
Christmas Carol right no Tim he's
referring to the singer uh yeah I mean
look at him he's spot on that one man so
good
so Jimmy I gotta say
and this short clip in a moment in
history if you don't look at anything
else in his life
specific Universe he crushed it
yeah it was good you know colored cream
yeah they're all different flavors
in his spot and I just love that so much
you know
seen the show tonight
okay [__] wrecked oh he's flat
bastard
oh [__] that was awesome all right wow I
love that all right all right yeah also
one show
oh the show don't worry about that love
the show is always happening oh yeah we
got another car bomb I want to point out
that Jimmy Lee link was number two in
our Doc and we are an hour and 35
minutes into the show so we are might be
a new record for us we are doing it good
Jimmy the Jimmy Lee thing is number two
of God I don't know a hundred
I think it's a new it's a new record for
us I was really happy we got through
those sponsors you know when we did
all right Irish [__] don't turn on
the engine
it's time for the juicer River that's
your way out of the car
is anyone else drinking with us because
I'm about to hit this [__]
I'm gonna go back to the Chernobyl yeah
I still got my Chernobyl going because
that's the best one that was the best
one of the year if I drink this I'm
gonna be gone gone
yeah
yeah a little worried can you wait a
little bit long we have the button
yeah but the button operator is pretty
toasty you don't have a button too
that's what I'm saying though dude once
you started drinking you went on a
tangent about String Theory I feel like
the more alcohol the less cancelable
yeah interesting surprisingly that's
what I feel should we test that theory
I'm a little afraid because Ethan thinks
he has a parachute now with the button
right sometimes do the car bomb men do
the column your your button operator
over here is a little little toasted
listen if you think I need to slam the
button just scream everybody screaming
scream okay all right here we go
hey
uh Hey two years don't start your engine
you understand
hey watch out for Main Street you
understand this one's for a free and
independent Ireland
[__] the English Invaders
beyond the payoff Beyond The Pale my ass
have you have you guys noticed that uh
our resident Brit here is the only one
not wearing green just saying crickets
over in Ian's land or AKA Beyond The
Pale Inn what the [__] you want to get
oh neither
there's the definition of green it's
very loose that is yellow loose in this
office that is yellow sir
show me your green Dan it's on my pants
I don't know if I can get my leg up that
eyeballs
River dancer way up Daniel okay so two
of us need to be pinched that's what
we've decided [__] out of Dance
all right cheers to the car bombs all
right may they may the Cotter bottoms be
over May the car bombs beef too
many car slam death to all Englishman
rest in peace
death to the queen Lizzy in a box
Cheers Cheers the thing about
[Applause]
shout out
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa it's not as easy as the first time
I think it would get easier
it's interesting
[Music]
you're doing great
busy in a box
[Music]
it's so crazy that they were singing
that I can't get over it the queen died
and there's and there's thousands of
people alive
level
[Music]
all right bye blast off I'm gone blast
off I don't think I've been this drunk
after this hits
since College I have another one
sure
sorry we're good
I'm sorry we're good uh since College
really I mean I know you were saying
you're not a big drinker but I don't
really ever get super trashed
trying to think like you've been drunk
since College
no but like maybe a few years for trash
wait wait the in Israel in Israel with
post Malone dude with post Malone right
yeah absolutely oh that night we got
absolutely lasted after the live show
that we did with post Malone and we went
to the rainbow
and he bought us like
three thousand dollars worth of shots it
was like just never ending yeah
that was a good night he's a good guy
um
so let's see here
uh maybe we can make it through the top
of the show yeah let's see okay so the
tick tock preacher is preaching about
semen that's right on uh brand here for
us all right all right another kind of
milk no it's another why are priests
talking so much about semen this video
is so sick this is the second preacher
we've had talking about save and brother
pretty bizarre it's the seed of the Gods
you know there's this really funny thing
it's not true but like I guess it was
being shared by on social media I don't
know it was some conspiracy propaganda
but there was this title that said
women this is so gross I shouldn't even
say it and I'm drunk It's just I'm ready
I'm ready I'm ready
I may be drunk but I have moved my mouth
I am one click away from women what even
no no no I've told you this before but
I'm not it's just actually so gross I
don't think it's offensive uh-oh type it
I'll type it yeah
this
is not your words you're just no no
recording something I've read people
saying this and what I thought was
reputable sources it's totally not true
people are wondering if you were just
gonna say women be shopping I know I
have a feeling it's worse than that
we'll see I see it in Discord Ethan is
typing typing for a while if you would
like to submit a button graphic I've
been adding new ones
this is just like propaganda by men and
I almost got
[Music]
so women who consume their partner see
men
increase their fertility and chance to
get pregnant yeah absolutely dumb and I
was like Ela did you know this
I had Kardashians you said you certainly
but yeah it was uh Courtney was trying
Courtney yeah Courtney with Travis yeah
Courtney and Travis were talking you
said it like as a serious thing or she
was joking no people think this is real
she was on like a specific cleanse
because they were trying the cement
cleanse no no no yes actually they they
weren't having sex for a for a minute
Plumbing Kardashians go no nut
but I guess but but then I Googled it
and they're like that's just not true
and I was like damn that kind of make
sense
be awesome if it was true though not
true
[Laughter]
it just felt really gross I was you see
I have more drunk Ethan is is more
you're more on the rails yeah you were
actually way more cautious I'm on the
rails baby
I love it
he says oh yeah you could say that
yesterday I typed something to Dan and
everyone's like do not do not say that
yeah you literally got vetoed by every
person in the building everyone's like
no no no no no no and you respected it
you really didn't want to respect it but
you did so I did yeah always listen to
Dan
so here let's talk it let's see what
these these preachers have to say about
same and Lord going all the way down and
they pulls the most scene
and they came back again
some more pools there yeah some more
still beings to the left some to the
right
of cement posted on each side they hit
Palace the size of an 18 with a going
down
it was open I did not understand word he
said y'all heard Stephen I didn't hear
anything
and they put some semen on top and then
he says I think uh the size of an 18
wheeler going down what is he talking
about
afternoon everyone where he goes after
everything he says I don't understand
baby can you do me a favor yeah
transcribe this video and then we'll
come back and watch it again with the
transcription yeah
what leads us to believe this is a
preacher okay
um it just says King Master King uh King
Master prophet
so does he have other videos where he's
just talking about like Jesus or
something
because just based on that video alone
it's hard to see preacher can I tell you
something I'd say this is a pretty
christ-like Buttercup sea cup or
Buttercup the horse the prize horse
this semen is so valuable you mean
Seabiscuit Sea Biscuit yes what are we
talking about the biscuit Buttercup the
horse
cousin sea biscuits even it's so
valuable imagine how much Jesus this
semen would be bro that [__] was wow
that car bomb's really getting there
dude
I'll tell you what bro I don't know
about mine but if you drink Jesus's
semen you'll be given birth All Day
Jesus said was no nut true he's donut
steamer retention that's how he got his
powers that's how he turned the water
hello I have a nut and 180 days Lord I'm
talking to God now I hear the voice of
God lord I have a jerk I have a nut in
367 days
I'm in psychosis brother I'm a prophet
of God I have a nut and 473 days
hitting me good boy I'm in this drunk in
a minute y'all you're very careful St
Patrick we love St Patrick now you know
this time last year we were in Vegas
it's making me miss love I remember bro
it's been a year oh that was been a year
what the [__] it's been more than a year
yeah I've been thinking about that we
should do that again that was a lot of
fun really fun you guys remember when
love got really red one night wait I got
so worried again you guys are like I
don't know what you guys were [__]
we're like you were really red yeah
a little bit so I don't know if we ever
told that we are sitting down eating
and somebody told me who told me like yo
loves getting really I think we all
started noticing it we noticed yeah he
looked like a hot Cheeto and I was like
I was like love your face
was this was this the night with the
magician was it when we went from
Mexican food was it that night yeah yeah
oh yeah the magician I forgot about that
dude yeah also I remember oh yes I
remember that some dude came into table
magic and then he was like he's like
asking for a tips like I didn't ask you
to come do magic for me we did different
yeah yeah we did we ended up we tipped
him of course we did it's such a rocket
he wasn't that good of a magician he was
really all right he was fine I remember
I was funk
dude that was the night love and I
walked through we didn't even talk about
this love and I walked around the Vegas
Strip like at two weeks that was wrong
we got the full Vegas experience we saw
somebody found the photo okay the best
thing yeah they took pictures of random
people and love posted like they were
famous yeah
and we saw we saw a scene of a stabbing
too it was oh my God yeah awesome you
guys are dominated the late night I got
my ass spanked yeah yeah yeah yeah wait
love didn't you run into some dude that
was like a streamer or something like
that or maybe I'm instrumental
remembering this I don't [__]
remember anything I'm kidding yeah I
have a I have a small memory over that
too yeah no we didn't finish the story
of Ethan getting I mean of love getting
red yeah but Ethan was worried about him
I was like maybe you should just go look
in the bathroom make sure you're okay
and so he was going to ELA told me like
maybe you should go with him make sure
he's all right all right I go into the
bathroom I follow love he looks in the
mirror he's like what the [__] I'm fine
he just walks out
I I cannot handle my uncle well so I can
drink a lot without being [__] up I
think I did drink a lot without uh
noticing it I was probably pretty
blasted yeah
okay you should wait until love comes
back and then we'll do another oh yeah
thank you I don't know it's coming back
hopefully sooner than that all right
well actually on that note uh I sent in
the visa application you did yesterday
yeah
so love is applying for a work visa via
our company we got a bunch of supporting
statements articles famous folks yes sir
very very kind very generous did they
did they did they say what's the
turnaround on that I love that you're
turning to Robert
why are you squinting
I've never been this drunk on the
podcast before buyers car bombs and like
three others surprisingly normal though
for how drunk you are no you
legitimately have been uh there's
nothing normal about this level of drug
let me think yeah he comes in my show
it's Friday
you talk to me like I'm somewhere
yeah it's a great screen it's clear it's
good enough yeah yeah I love the big
chair you look just tell me one thing
what toppings do you want on your Beats
I don't think we talked about when we
saw Chris Angel either in Vegas
oh my God we totally did fine freak we
didn't we didn't
like um we want hotel where we at but no
it was Planet Hollywood and we ate at
his steak wasn't in a private room yeah
wait wait but you Ethan you and I were
outside and a b was there too yeah we
were having one we're like Chris
[Applause]
yeah right because at the steakhouse we
were eating at next floor was the
theater where mind Chris Angel did his
show yeah yeah and so we're like oh
Chris Angel's here huh whatever and then
we went in and we looked through the on
the way to the bathroom on the right
there's like a window
yeah the VIP room and Chris Angel was
there chatting up someone and we're like
later that night yeah we're outside it's
me Zach and Ethan and Ethan's looking at
a photo Chris Angel he's like look at
this [__] guy he's like a realtor
that photos
and then Chris Angel walks by and Zach's
like hey Chris Chris is like hey buddy
because the thing is it's all over Vegas
you see these Billboards of Chris Angel
and he's like jacked his abs are out
he's hot you know but when you look in
there that's like Chris like Chris like
Vegas version He Ain't No Angel yeah
Chris uh he's like Chris car salesman
yeah
they ain't no [__] angel I was just a
dude named Chris in that [__] AB room
he's slamming States
happy birthday
[Applause]
thank you guys I'm a little offended by
the cake but thank you guys that's your
best photo you wanted to honor you with
the most photogenic photo we can find
him thank you thank you the photo that
ruined my life I appreciate it thank you
everyone right Amy yes sir
that's a real big one bro I would get on
a bus right now to Vegas who want who's
getting on it let's go let's go I'm
already there wait I have kids
for everyone to Japan right now dude
let's go to Japan I want to go to Japan
Japan's [__]
don't even say that take that back or
I'm hitting the button
can I say thank you Gabor for the fight
can I say a little birthday speech real
quick okay this time last year we were
all in Vegas and uh it was right before
my fight and that was when Brett brought
his first photo and he looked massive
and I was like terrified
um and it was really [__] with me and
you guys guys were all there for me you
guys were my family away from home and
uh I really appreciate you guys and
thank you so much oh yeah
yeah
oh yeah brother Abdullah
you're the best you're gonna [__]
kill him too yeah that's right Dad is
the best year we're going for the kill
hell yeah
for all of us collectively through ABC
figuratively
literally dies no not literally dad's in
a figurative sense [__] because the
music of that cake
give Ethan my give me Ethan my face why
are you squinting
bright right now oh my God
Everything feels so bad
all right let's talk about something
else
so that preacher loves semen did you
transcribe that yet baby yeah Olivia's
on it right it's been about an hour
it's been about seven minutes
I am almost done with what I think he's
saying okay let me know so you guys you
guys can like proofread yeah just just
make sure you get down
I am I am transformed
you know those of you who have a long
time uh fans of the show know that I
have a particular obsession with funny
scooter videos
out the Gatsby I love when handicapped
people are well wheelchair-bound people
just go bug wild and that was in those
cars because let's be real
they're a risk in society those cars are
no joke
and this video approves scooter the
scooters the car they're little they're
little mobiles bro
it's more than a scooter they're little
mobiles they're little mobiles okay so
this person was in Goodwill and there's
no good will left let me tell you it's
called bad will after after they were
done with it all right let's see
I purposely didn't watch this one
because I want to be surprised so we got
a wheelchair person that's looking for a
bit and you know
we see this a lot
whoa
holy [__] they can't stop the
acceleration oh my God they can't stop
it [__] idiot bro for whatever reason
they just can't slow it down it's like a
train
you know and so here we go and this this
poor person just gets caught in the
crossfire and I didn't even notice that
person only she said gone she collapsed
yo
bro thought he was going to Narnia bro
that's good love the capture is working
at Goodwill be like this
WOW funny yeah that's a powerful one
it's been so long since we got a good
one of these I don't know absolutely man
when we first kind of got on this train
yeah we watched everything that was out
there yeah exactly but do you know why
was that because of Kobe dude
[Music]
but they're coming back now well we had
decades worth of untapped oil reserves
yeah right that makes a harvest can we
just take a minute to honor Mobility
Mary rest in peace go oh Mobility let's
I drink to that oh this beautiful St
Patrick's Day
I take a ride to Valhalla with her bro
I just re-watched almost I would ride to
heaven with her where all may all your
ramps be accessible
right and all your doors be
automatically opening May there be no
joggers uh slow on the sidewalk in front
of you may your roads be clear and open
to you Mobility Mary may heaven God damn
I'm calm the [__] laptop
what my sandal got grabbed up in the
wires and I was all caught up in this
[__] oh you know you're starting to
remind me of shoe nice oh no no
give me a tampon I'm about to eat that
I think it's the splending of the eyes
maybe he does that I don't know
uh Eden races
here's the further fun button repairs I
love you all favorite podcast to listen
to while I work
on charting therapy notes I don't know
what the [__] that means I imagine
they're a therapist and they're taking
notes about their patients you're not
you're taking notes about me Jim you
might need to P.S I love Sam you've been
in a pristine and appreciated
[Applause]
no I just and camera I think we'd be
cute together she said Kim oh oh
thoughts
I don't know
we'll have to take her workout
that's a giant whoa look at your piece
you really saved me this honored piece
Lena
wow bro
[Laughter]
is real oh my thank you
eat that [__]
eat Amy's face do it
hang it on your laptop
[Music]
people are saying you had a Wendy moment
with that burp
it was cake is busting I gotta go
bathroom
no I have to pee already again
I'll I'll stay uh
we play musical chairs again keep that
finger on the button like chemicals yeah
the finger is on the button
this Cake's pretty good yeah
love that you're eating it like a
sandwich I need like
wipe it on a shirt dude you're good
Jesus
there are paper towels at your feet yeah
there's a paper towels yeah you can
clean yourself up you're looking
directly you're literally looking at
them they're right where you're looking
where are the paper towels
do you need help hold on kidding yeah
okay
you need help
this is the reality I love that average
people this is the reality right here
buddy that's right this is a reality
where you never met Ela my hair I'm
getting drunk and eating cake all day I
love Irish people that's right I love St
Patrick he was a good dude man I love St
Patrick that man [__] [__] snakes up
oh yeah I hate snakes
and thanks to St Patrick
I don't have to ever [__] with snakes
I'm so thankful to him let's play the
podcast Ireland can we do an Irish live
show Let's do an Irish live show what
does that mean we probably owe it to our
Irish fans after all yeah the Irish
things
so they don't want us there yeah we
might be banned after this episode
Irish fans we love you it's all in good
fun and we we did not mean no I hate
Irish people okay
can you can you mute his mic
you just straight up mute his mic please
now we love the Irish people uh we want
to free an independent Ireland
truck yard law Bobby said potatoes shut
up
oh yeah where's my potato
es thank you thank you Zach Olivia can
you take over for me I gotta pee again
yeah I have to pee so bad also after you
okay
oh okay Olivia just Olivia she just ran
into the Scorpion chair
that's true
got done
Olivia ladies and gentlemen
a real moment would you love the Irish
people I love them Eli your mic is open
but uh Ethan we've caught Ethan's Mike
who's popping off
don't you love the Irish
you tell me what you want to say I'll
say it on your
[Music]
you're insulting ab's Heritage right now
I'm my [__] birthday
seriously
Lucky Charms actually had a few days ago
yeah
and uh can can our Irish and Scottish
fans uh out there do me a favor I've
always been like what what's the reality
of the relationship between the Scots
and the Irish because I feel like as as
a half Scotsman myself I feel a certain
kinship you're [__] Scottish Ireland
but uh I'm half Scottish yeah you never
told me this
I've mentioned earlier this episode he's
also
all right open Ethan's mic back up he's
also half Jewish AP I mean does that bug
you at all or yeah you got a problem
with that half no no how about how about
you guys you guys care that I'm I'm half
error [__] no
Mac and I thought my mind was muted
these guys are doing a mutiny on me I
see we love these shots we're allies
allies okay hell yeah hell yeah hell
yeah to the Irish I figured because just
as an American knowing like the dynamic
of like both of them kind of hating the
English I figured you'd be United on
that but I I didn't know for sure so
thank you for the clip could I ask you a
question genuinely who likes the English
I love Ian we love Ian Ian's the one
he's one of the good ones
who likes the English like genuinely who
likes the English they were the super
villains I didn't and then I met every
person I know in my life that's English
I love
literally love I I I mean on the show a
lot about like [__] the English because
it's just kind of like a funny meme but
but
I have to say not English people so why
do you mean [__] uh Luke is like the
greatest dude I know
English people are bad but what are you
saying well like the same way who likes
America doesn't like American people
specific American people
I'm saying who likes the English this is
the race episode
you know this is not a conversation
literally all periods all of my favorite
musicians are English that's true oh
yeah I also like as much as I meme on
the English and yours too that no I
agree yeah they have good music Banger
music from England Great art and great
art fashion I mean what are we even
talking about why are we even because
it's just imperialism it's because that
you know the United States was a colony
of the Britain and we broke away and so
there's like an everlasting sort of like
oh [__] you British we okay
it's not Siri
in a box
[Music]
that's so wild dude we also we pulled
their ass out of the fire and World War
Two world we saved their ass yeah that's
right so they owe us we earned it Ian
thanked me for that
smacking that's why we can kind of dunk
on the French too we saw their asses I
got this transcribed
you guys ready
uh preacher okay yeah let's hear it
so this is what I'll read what I think
he says and then we'll watch it okay
gotten drunk
going all the way down
all the way down okay and then that
sounds pretty accurate and then they
pour some more seam in there
and then they put some steel this course
and they put some steel beans close
and its course from the left yeah and
you cross it from the left and of course
it from the right
hand and they put some semen on top man
sick of it
some more pours out some more pools
there some more still Paws huh so we'll
still beings to the left to the left to
the right thumb to the right to the
center huh
it went from the seven feet it was 37
feet of Fame and pulse and I of cement
potion on the side on this side they get
Palestine they hit Palace
so it still makes no sense it makes no
sense sorry I'm incredible at
transcription
[Music]
that puts some cement on top and then
they come back again 30 feet of cement
sick of it some more men pour around
to the left to the right
complaining about construction maybe
he's like going off with the noise
oh now I get it noise ornaments
the literally the construction
that makes sense still odd all right I
really have to
by the way
number three ladies and gentlemen two
hours in I have a question do you click
the yellow or the red okay so yeah
yellow is video yeah the red is audio
you want to click both oh you want to do
both yeah you want to do both I'm glad I
asked
foreign
people asking about my Visa 45 days is
um
oh that's not too long no it's not too
bad that's not bad at all so by the
quartering put out a new thumbnail about
Brie Larson you guys know he's obsessed
with them
actually scary you should get a
restraining order this man built a shed
called the Brie Larson shed that he
built with AdSense made from Brie Larson
videos this is an actual thumbnail on
his shadow
sure
I made you read the eyes man but you
lost it fires back at Diva claims as the
Marvel is to set to be the biggest flop
in Marvel history
so this is the thumbnail
by the way she once was like on Jimmy
Kimmel and he uses her from the show and
this outfit like every time just because
of the cleavage and titties
but I want to do say I do respect Jeremy
for the inspiration he provided I sent
in Discord because we thanks to Ryan or
Harvey he was referring to the show made
this thumb now and we've replaced it
with the current one
you look good thank you so that's my
body you do your hair what happened
that is my actual somebody's different
about you on this thumbnail but I can't
tell what just the lighting just the
lighting
hmm
so there it is so congratulations to
Jeremy he's always keeping it classy
[Music]
apparently I've called Dan dad many
times three times to be specific people
have gone through the anals of hit of HP
podcast history anals pulled me calling
Dan dad that's dad now I did see a
comment of a speech therapist who's like
yeah Ethan has dyslexia or whatever and
he scores
the n and it sounds like a d okay so Dan
is not well here let me just play it
sure I'll pull up there can you hear
dad's trip dance chip bag oh my dad
sorry Dan
and his dad said or I just called you
Dad okay well I'm admitting it there I
meant to call you Dan
[Laughter]
thought a little weird
Daddy
obviously they sound close yes we'll let
it slide it was a typo don't let it
happen again
and then Dad said something I had the
button now
bad bad
[Music]
you know what I'd be cool if Dan was my
dad I'll just be real about it right
dad's I love my dad but
right now he's not here Dan if he
adopted me if he raised me he wasn't
there he's at the store he played ball
with me that's what it would look like
if you think Dan would be absent I mean
he would be woke as [__]
woke is an offensive term Maybe
I'd be socially conscious please don't
use that word offensive
hey did you guys know we got in
communication with a Nook
finally a Nook of course who is our
favorite
uh we've been trying and trying and
trying to get make contact with yeah and
he followed the podcast on Instagram
it literally changed our lives he sent
us this beautiful message wait hold on
him to call in but yeah I need to hold
on a second I just got back
and I looked at the chat and everybody's
saying audio
are we having the issue again audio
uh oh one second well if you said it was
for one second this is what happens
you missed a beautiful moment Ethan said
he wishes you were his dad yeah
hold on a second I just got back
and I looked at the chat and everybody's
saying audio
I've been messing with you again
audio this sounds totally clean audio is
fine somebody said I literally got back
and it's fine now they're trolling you
once again calling us
my aura is literally holding the show
together that's not very nice you guys
some people are saying it's my mind
your mic is cracking I've seen that in
chat if you I just seen right now a few
people said Amy's Mike
uh uh it wasn't audio okay everybody's
saying it's totally fine now all right
well sorry about that uh I guess I fixed
it I'm so good I guess I'm just that
cool I'd walk in a room and it's getting
fixed yeah thanks Dad it was bad for
like two seconds okay okay thanks
um
so just so everybody knows uh I I have a
pretty good idea of what is causing the
issue and I have uh purchased a solution
uh it actually just arrived this morning
it's in a box that's sitting behind my
chair so I will uh probably be
implementing it on Monday morning and we
should be good from now on It's the
final solution
the final solution to the audio problem
just to be clear
not
not the final solution not the uh the
other question got it final
if you you are half Jewish which one I
am half Jewish yes okay I can I can toe
the line there
um the nons the non-scottish half if you
would like to make a button graphic of
uh we'll be right back feel free to
submit it to our subreddit I'll be I'm
adding new ones now if you want to make
a new one you want to exercise your
creativity muscle over the weekend make
a 16x9 we'll be right back graphic I'll
add a bunch of them to the lineup
because you know we'll be hitting that
button over the year yeah this is your
chance to get it uh on the show
thank you Cam yeah that'll be great I
have there was already some great ones
on the subreddit and we've already
implemented that into the loop uh some
very funny ones uh but the more the
merrier yeah
I think we should do the Shakira section
when Ethan gets back I think it'd be so
funny with drunkies I think yeah it'd be
good to see him put it together oh yeah
it's juicy okay I don't know what's
happening with her it's a PowerPoint
we're about to fill you in yeah just you
wait
you're about to know everything about it
all right we're gonna just
jump right into it
somebody said uh the Windows XP graphic
is the best that that was a cam
invention actually of course it was of
course the best damn imagine yeah
[Applause]
hey I love you guys we should really
start feeding I love you guys
we should we are just best friends
are we best friends are we best friends
right now Olivia I love those sunglasses
by the way thank you thank you
they're from Amazon
they're very 2005. are we doing yeah
thank you guys
outfit do you want to try yeah I want
they're probably not gonna look good on
me for some reason I have a feeling love
St Patrick
what a turnaround yo I just saw
something weird I was taking a whiz
and so I went to Russell Brands somebody
retweeted Russell Brand oh it's Jordan
Peterson of course they look amazing
Mila yeah
Russell Brand
he follows 668 people so he's not a bot
you guys want to do this sunglasses
I'll take her back
that's the vibe we'll go back to
browsing Twitter Russell Brand follows
me wait wait
he only has 668 he only follows 668
people he follows me do you think we
could get him I feel like that could
actually be interesting because you know
he's had this like slide to the right
recently but he used to be a lot so yeah
right there me and Zach would like that
we knew that he follows you wait we've
talked before yeah back in February 2020
he said I will come on your show email
me he used to be a Marxist too but I
think did we ever I don't know whatever
happened no no we did I actually it's
coming back I was here um let me search
my email I remember we did have a little
exchange and
for some reason it just didn't work out
it was like sorry I've been calling I
mean daily yeah I'm I'm going to rumble
yeah Rumble Rumble says I can't talk to
you sorry bro
Rubble says you're not cool I can talk
to you
yeah let's let's oh I know what happened
what happened you know when this email I
I have an email with his uh team and
it's on February 9th 2020 right before
covet hit oh
was he gonna come in person that was the
original plan oh that was this was
pre-locked yo let's set it up
yeah let's set it up Rumble Rumble me
Tom could be interesting I used I used
to like I used to like him too
I hope you don't drunk text him Rumble
me bumble right now I didn't but what
should I say yo let's set it up yo
Russell better late than never yo
Russell your homie yo Russell Crowe
yeah whatever you're doing is gonna
he just did a thing with uh Stephen
Crowder he's on Rumble which is like a
conservative like pedophile and uh
vampire but I thought that he was not a
conservative he is he he went is I would
say I met him at a movie
and he went dark they paid him a lot of
money I remember it does he used to be
an interesting guy I don't know yeah
last I remember he was not that yeah
yo let's set it up but are you sure you
want to be able to set it up that's it
that's kind of weird just coming out of
the blue yeah yeah what do you want me
to say that's why I'm thinking maybe
maybe tell them you're drunk like hey
sorry I'm drunk that's the worst you
look like such a weirdo
I'm kidding oh you're kidding he was
just uh let's just put the phone away
for a minute but I don't forget people
saying uh Russell Brand is not on the
right guys uh he didn't used to be I I
find it a little more
this was not the case like a few years
ago he's like three years he's on Rumble
what more do you need to know he's a
great well I agree like this man made a
video called hang fauci
I said what the [__] Russell I did he
really say that you feel like on my
boots that's not a good joke you make it
sound like you're actually so funny well
you make it sound like you actually did
that but he basically did without the
cult of violence
without that part
let's go
idiot
I think he seems like he'd be willing to
uh to speak with us
he was married to Katy Perry you know
that for a minute yeah we don't hold
that against him though well no we but I
mean they're both I guess if you want to
go but she posted a like an endorsement
for
um Gavin Newsom
yeah that Newsome Rick Caruso oh that's
yeah yeah
she's taking the right chasing the rules
she wants to take a crew a Rick Caruso
take a cruise so true what are we
ordering I'm hungry he's a [__]
let's get pizza that'll make you happy
no
Eden says here's here's the further fun
button repairs I love you all favorite
podcast to listen to while I work on
charting therapy now we read this
is so long but Camp do you have a type
is thick Latina therapist who Thrift her
outfits in there somewhere oh yeah sure
is that your type uh a cam I don't have
a type you don't have a type you open
everything yeah you got to happen even
brother there's got to be at least let's
not suck physically but there's got to
be some kind of personality you
gravitate to call it green yeah what
kind of girl you like what kind of
flavors I don't know I like creative
people creative Ethan can I offer you
water at this trying time right now uh
that's actually probably a good idea all
of us that have been drinking yeah is it
alcohol like 90. let's get 100 water in
you chug chug chug chug yeah yeah all
right ending the show in five minutes
yeah uh do you guys want to hear uh some
breaking rather sad news no not a
passing no no moving on
no never mind no who died
Lance Riddick died I know the [__] that
is you do know who he is even if you
don't know the name
good Riddick good riddance the Riddick
too soon it was in The Wire uh oh no
yeah
he's so awesome great I am very uh wait
how did it so dude that man was like he
was only 60. he wasn't that old he was
so healthy too he's like so it was a
great escape I don't know what happened
anything else Dan
I did saw it right before we went live
Friday again Friday I just felt like rip
Zavala that's right he voiced one of the
main characters in uh there's no Intel
on on
whatever I don't there might be I I saw
it like when it was posted like 10
minutes ago so oh no not very much
information
uh that's horrible everybody should go
and watch the wire if you haven't yeah
one of the best shows of all time we
just started me and Lena oh you know you
just started it yeah it's a slow burn
maybe but it's worth the investment
that's what I keep saying I see it on
the top of like every list of top shows
so once you get invested in the
characters because it's a slow burn it's
really about the story and characters
don't push
Ed the first like 10 minutes of it a few
times because every time we started I
fall asleep yeah yeah it takes a little
bit it's kind of like that the first
getting into it but then it's like it's
so good
it's kind of like that yeah do you guys
want y'all want some pizza though oh I'm
not being in the chat uh it's a hard no
what's c a Sam so I guess he he had
let's see A's
Maza
what's Za he's uh
you never heard zaw you guys know let's
get some Za bruh wait can you say that
you really never heard yeah yeah we
again are you that's like a SoCal you
don't want some zabra I think I already
said no like you had a burrito I didn't
eat [__] I ate [__] I I said like
even if I was starving that would be the
answer though okay I hate her you don't
like pizza huh you're anti Pizza it's St
Patrick's Day
[Music]
no I know you don't want pizza do you
have another suggestion for food are you
not hungry I'm honestly not hungry but I
would go for a boba but you should not
do that to yourself
every time eats your something bad then
it feels like [__] the whole evening
well I'm already drunk so yeah we had
some busting food the other day to
yourself what was that that fish place
we had oh sweet fin sweet fin that was
good what's sweeping don't you need some
crust to soak up yeah fish and booze
doesn't go well you know we need
I tried you guys are bad influence I try
to Elijah
Elijah can I get a pizza with I said
both I want bacon black olives diarrhea
and boogers
whenever I'm trying to joke with
Theodore boogers vomit puke and piss is
all the jokes it's like how about a poop
smoothie with a puke and boogers
he's a little comedian bro we're talking
about boogers and [__] look on meaty
yo let's get some of that though I want
bacon
I can't believe you're black olives
you're gonna regret this you regret it
I'm already annoying
no you're not what's the problem you can
still eat healthy okay what should I eat
then anything but Pizza okay y'all got
six I do want Boba but that's a drink
get a sandwich you understand carving
board get a boba Sandwich Car bread
pizza these nuts
[Music]
yeah
nothing wrong with calling it early man
oh stop it Zach
we asked we asked our uh babysitter if
she could stay late that doesn't mean
late go ahead dab me up girl
that [__] up right now for some
bacon hell no
oh
jingle those
three
I remember it was about ricegum but I
remember the words I know your dad's a
fan of this Dan huh you should say your
dad was a fan of this beat of the
ricegum song yeah me yeah maybe he told
me at one point my dad my dad's uh my
dad's a low-key fan he watches is your
dad accepting uh applications for being
it for son okay
that's so sweet my dad asked me when I
was in Michigan he goes you still work
on that show right you're not you're not
just you're not just boxing I swear to
God he asked me if I'm just boxing I'm
like you know I had one why and I lost
right
[Music]
Wow Let's see black we can relate with
it because he was a boxer right so yeah
all of a sudden he was like well you're
boxing okay yeah okay he wasn't a
[__] Apollo Creed right he just Sam
what's the ET on pizza if you're looking
uh she's African
I haven't ordered anything so I don't
know no but like you can see on post
rates
Olivia was gonna do this you're uh
PowerPoint can we do yeah let's do the
Shakira PowerPoint that I think that's
cute yeah
I would order from Domino's Direction
it's usually about 20 minutes or so can
we get someone else like [__] dominoes
can we get like a mom and pop sure my
mom and Bob like Bingo mom and pop
dominoes can suck my [__] that's why
I'm I hate pizza because like why do I
want to eat this crap no Domino's can
[__] lick my hairy [__] dude
Lucifer Pizza dude Lucifer Domino's can
clean my [__] of all the dangle
berries bro and let me live my life what
do you got back there Sam
I'm checking hold on one second I mean
you don't want to learn about the
Shakira drama I do but there's priority
like what like getting the pizza order
right isn't temporary and then as
they're bringing it we talk about
Shakira
her hips don't lie everything is about
30 minutes 30 minutes is fine 30 to 40
minutes 30 is good 40 is so you want
bacon
black olives you find a good you good
spot there's there's several options
yeah I want bacon I want diarrhea I'm
like boogers all right if you want ear
wow you got to make a reorder and Cube
shavings you got to make a real order if
you want this to happen I want to play
the game I want to play a game you want
pineapple Olive and uh whatever the
other thing you got is oh yeah yeah
black olive black olive pineapple
pineapple jalapeno jalapeno and oh my
God okay
you got it okay all right
like too loud
oh boy man we're gonna be sleeping Ethan
you need to smoke you good you know
smoke oh my God I could totally have
white cigarettes
I bet it's been written so long I've
been so good I know I've been on that uh
Nicorette but you know people go oh you
can stop chewing I say okay I'll just
have a cigarette then haters
no you should stop chewing I know it's
mode no I asked the GPT 4.0 last night I
asked GPT 4.0 does Nicorette gum
nicotine gum cause cancer they said
there is no link between nicoricum but
it didn't end there
well there's some yeah there's adverse
effects to eating [__] you know
you're asked the chatbot what'd you name
the chatbot when you chew it you gotta
follow the instructions and you don't
you chew it for the whole for hours
you're living in your mouth you're not
supposed to do that well just push
put the gum up here dude he doesn't do
that he's doing it like oh it's not like
a snooze low that's nothing
no you don't I see you you're chewing it
like a normal oh you're watching now I
chew my gum
you keep the tabs on how the what the
the movement of my gum in my mouth uh
yeah yeah I'm sure you're keep it cool
oh the gum today was in the coordinates
of uh the left cheek of Ethan's Garden
for me you chew so loud I don't need to
pay that much attention
gum
why are we on like self-destruction mode
right now can we talk about that
self-destruction snickering gum the GPT
4.0 said no link between Cancer
okay what do you want to eat though
because I know you don't like pizza do
you want like a calzone a salad some
pasta what do you like no I don't want
anything you want to find the soup I
gotta get a burrito right before you
want to tear them a poo
no brother no brother I want to tell you
brother
[Music]
all right everybody tell what kind of
Sam Sam what kind of pizza you want
everybody tell Pizza what kind of salmon
you want what kind of sandwich
give my boys some sigis and some bacon
there
[Music]
we hit it
any other drink Ethan yeah
guys nobody I think I got it right
that was a total accident that was an
accident yeah Nicorette gum yeah
they're gonna think I did something I'm
like
[Music]
all right seeing the chat go crazy
there's no way that that didn't work
right maybe because that was like right
up I think we should we should just move
on but I'll listen yeah it doesn't
matter if they didn't see it it's all
good
you know the craziest part of the lore
videos is seeing you smoke in the studio
bro you have a cigarette right yeah cam
this is the fake ones we were talking
about it when we this Dan retrospective
or whatever you want to call it uh there
was like a long section
where everybody in the studio is smoking
I was like oh yeah we used to [__] do
that that's kind of insane back during
the post Malone day we would just chain
smoking that tiny space
office what is it oh [__] queen baby
what can we so we can't smoke in here
anymore or anything you can smoke I
don't care but it's no don't no I do no
no no
nobody smokes inside hi this is 2023.
well Zach like I was gonna say it's if
the other people don't want second hand
smoke then we respect that right we
don't thank you yeah um mostly just
because I'll really want a cigarette if
you start right I don't want to smoke so
please keep it away when the um guy from
Google that engineer that got laid off
from AI stuff came in his son was just
lighting up a blunt in our office
didn't even ask for permission we just
told him to take it outside
it's not that yeah people just yeah
he was a wild child
I respected it dude let's see what else
is on let's do the Shakira thing yeah
it'll be really funny when it with you
in this we have been meaning to do
Shakira for a while so are you ready for
that Olivia
she's so ready so do I need to uh
uh do you want me to is it a little I
can put it on my screen yeah go ahead
you can pile it in all right I'll pilot
it
yeah and then if you have any questions
you can just read off of it but if you
have any questions just let me know all
right so here we are
you seeing this
hello
am I say yeah you're putting your order
hips don't lie but men do Shakira Gerard
Peak and Clara chicha mitcha Beach
mm-hmm yes you ready
what am I what do you guys want
something from me you're right I I
should just you're the pilot I'm the
pilot you're right here we are I just
taste weird did you really put alcohol
in this Olivia okay yeah oh you're
drinking more I don't know if there's a
conspiracy to make me sober I put one
shot of rum thank you Queen what's the
drink in here like Diet Coke Coke Zero
Coke Zero that's nice that's nice
I think I would give you a Diet Coke
[Applause]
okay so what's the deal with Shakira huh
yeah so Olivia you want to take us
through this well Ethan if you wanna you
can read all the prompts okay in 2010
there was a meeting
2011 confirmed dating between I'm
assuming that Shakira and who's that on
the right it says it on the bottom
Gerard pick pick pick
try to pick me
Shakira and her partner of 11 years
Gerard picked me met while on the set of
her music video of a 2010 World Cup
soundtrack song Waka Waka
this time for Africa they was called
this time for Africa it was called
what's what is this that's a banger
what's this you remember that one dude
yeah bro it's 2010 for Africa so this
year's for Africa that year was that was
a long time ago ever years for Africa
what is
time for Africa wasn't there a Muppet
baby that was waka waka uh Fozzie Bear
would say waka waka you're right I'm
assuming this is referring to wakawaka
African phrase though so pick a line
knock knock
babies we talk about Africa
this time for Africa man
that felt really racist
what you did is Jamaican accent which
isn't Jamaica is not in Africa so what
yeah
Gerard on after he and Shakira met
the details showed that she liked me we
started messaging each other during the
World Cup but the only chance I'd get to
Sierra was if we made the final because
she was performing in the closing
ceremony wait you guys missed go back
one cool
soccer player yes he's a soccer player
soccer player yes he plays for where
Spain so he was in the World Cup yeah
famous in the World Cup yeah 2010 and
they won oh world to 2010 okay
a center text to find out what the
weather was like [__] you don't have
Google
it's 2010.
excuse me
[__] raisin in Texas
shut up dude Google was around in 2010
idiot suppose that's not the best pickup
line here hey what's the weather like I
sent her a text to find out what the
weather was like since we were arriving
a few days later in general when you ask
a question this stupid okay he knows it
you get answer like it's cold bring a
coat but she wrote a long paragraph with
details about the change in temperature
during the day she turned into a
meteorology
I said to myself Jesus that's not normal
what okay the details show that she
liked me she's like cloudy with the
chance of rain he's like this she wants
me
we started messing each other during the
World Cup but the only chance I'd get to
see her was if we made the final because
she was performing in the closing
ceremony so I told her if I had to make
it all the way to the final just to see
her I would that's okay that's better
now we're talking that's better than
what's the weather yeah yeah upgrade
okay wow happy ending that kids Shakira
and joab never legally tied the knot
okay
but remained a couple for 11 years and
had two sons together well that's
beautiful nice
Milan and Sasha
cool cute very cute
in June 2022 that's very recently
Shakira and pick
me
announced that they would be breaking up
in a joint statement released by their
team we regret to confirm that we are
partying wise for the well-being of our
children who are our highest border we
ask that you respect their privacy thank
you for understanding
okay
cheating rumors begin to swirl two
months oh I think you arrived 36 was
seen at a music festival publicly
kissing Clara Chia Martini what the [__]
Clara
Marty the uh
a 23 year old bro are you serious right
now a 23 year old public relations
student who lives in Barcelona you're
[__]
lady
just she [__] destroyed her body
right two boys for you and now you're
gonna go [__] a 20 year old shame on you
pig nice thank you there you go what a
pig bro what a pig [__] you bro no peek
your penis got blasted in thirst for my
little kid and then you like try to find
a lover I have to necessarily yeah
hold on go back I didn't finish it
the two attended a wedding together not
long after they were photographed
together in August
hey good luck with him chia
dude just [__] moves on once you hit
25 apparently
Shakira since shaded her ex in multiple
songs queen go off a she-wolf like me
isn't for guys like you
oh oh oh
for guys like you oh oh oh oh I was out
of your league and that's why you're was
someone just like you oh oh oh oh
oh oh
I'm worth two 22 year olds you traded in
a Ferrari for a twingo what's a twingo
no I don't know kind of like a European
car brand probably some [__] I'm
sure you traded in a Rolex foreign
yeah it's like
oh it is a Renault there you go oh that
ain't no kind of car you want to be
driving if you're trying to [__]
that ain't no car bro that ain't no car
about to get you laid
okay
pop off Shakira
right yeah yeah you good you get through
this I mean I did read everything on
that I just wasn't sure if you got past
so how did Shakira find out Gerard was
cheating good question
[Music]
strawberry jam
I don't that's just okay we like okay I
guess we'll find out why page six
reported in January that during a
December 2022 appearance on the Spanish
speaking show socialite Shakira reveals
she discovered her ex was cheating on
her after returning home from a trip to
discover someone had been eating her
favorite strawberry jam while she was
away she claimed that neither her
children nor pick me like the jam which
tripped her off that something was going
on no way wow exposed strawberry jam so
smart somebody came into her house like
while he's cheating on her he would
bring that person to the house to eat
the jams Jam breakfast is a specific
yeah when you're cheating it's literally
her Jam he was eating not only literally
Not only was she eating her Jam but she
was also eating
the him gym
totally inappropriate yeah all right
okay she's quite literally the queen of
jam
beautiful
grams don't lie they Jam don't lie and
January 25 2023 the couple which is
Gerard and Clara the new uh
uh new girl Judith says uh maybe we just
call it Judas or he's Judas you can but
really the blame should be on him it is
it is yeah she's just like cool then why
not yeah whatever they went Instagram
official one of the top comments is
wait you can leave pictures on Instagram
yeah what you can now comment gifts
I have a few people have done it on my
photos I got so confused at first dude
this man will never stop getting Shakira
gifts as long as he lives yeah can't you
just not [__] a 20th year old just be
with your kids bro be with your wife you
scumbag you loser it looks like they're
really young right like they're that
girl is the babies the baby yeah 2013
2015. yeah like real just jerk off the
you know you mean like it's not that
serious just be with your kids it's way
more important would you want the
respect of your children you [__] also
your girl is also your own
wife
she's gonna be one of the most desirable
women in the world literally perfect if
Shakira gets cheated loyalty like you
guys had kids together yeah half
Lebanese Queen where's the Loyalty bro
that's right I didn't know if I believed
it until she is a tax fraud and then I
was like she's one of us
wait what
oh she is one of us she's going to jail
for tax problems she is one of us wait
wait maybe you can make that joke I
don't know
to jail for real I didn't hear I don't
know what uh yeah no in Spain I believe
she uh she got busted for uh not paying
your taxes yes oh Queen that's Queen
Behavior
no it's not well she got caught so
Spanish government has charged a care
with defrauding the country of 14.5
million euros in taxes one of us one of
us
that's not fraud that's just being smart
you know how many insurance jobs are in
my hometown it's [__] insane y'all
don't believe in taxes they'd be I pay
my taxes I'm just saying the same
restaurant caught on fire like three
times it's suspicious
you got to do what you got to do that's
that's a universe to be fair that's a
Griff that everybody wrong message from
you because you very much do pay your
taxes so I'm not I know you're kidding
but I don't know I don't yeah I'm not
here to admit that I'm committing
federal crime we don't [__] with the IRS
no I pay my taxes I pay so much in taxes
y'all would [__] cry if you saw what
I pay you would Cry tears of pain you
would look to the sky and say why God I
actually like that you pay that much in
taxes
you know I wouldn't mind it if people
had like Universal Health Care and it
wasn't just paying for like cruise
missiles to blow up the Iraqi villagers
okay that's a very fair point but the
fact that I'm extremely Fair Point 55
taxes to [__] kill like children in
Iraq yeah not that dumb okay
die children in Iraq who are minding
their own business picking like [__]
gym
that's awesome that's America baby
and that's what it's all about right ELO
that's what it's all about me up for
that stab me up
[__] beautiful God bless America
blowing up farms and Iraq in Afghanistan
while children in America die of cancer
that's America
durable blindness being treated by
distribution
[Music]
classes
thank you because you're clout goggles
goggles
[Laughter]
Kill Bill scissor scissor look your hip
Schism yes yes
which ain't nothing to [__] with ready
though
[Music]
enter the 36th Chambers at 36 Chambers
God damn it Olivia why'd you give him
those glasses yeah all right all right
ready the button when when these glasses
you're good you're good about street
cred 36 Chambers I get it I don't think
scissor was in Wu-Tang then okay
Valentine's Day
uh wait what happened
I think you're confusing it with with
[__] from now
I understand why you got confused I'm so
confused I'm not following anything
you're saying yeah but that makes sense
[Laughter]
she's amazing I love her so much more
though she was in Wu-Tang
and thank you Bryce for the gift we love
you all thank you so much happy St
Patrick's Day everybody
are saying she did base her name off of
Rizza so it is very understandable that
you got it confused is but yeah not
actually directly affiliated with the
Wu-Tang Clan wants us to say Irish
wristwatch
I don't know why but there it is okay
what else you want me to say like I'm a
[__] monkey I'm a tap dance for you
what else you want me to say
a trick
big black bug bled blue black blood
okay you want to say that no okay
so let's see uh Shakira She says scissor
Kill Bill [__] where is she mopping
up a murder which is kind of a serve in
Minecraft
wow okay she wrote the lyrics this is
Olivia commentary I might kill my ex
not the best idea
his new girlfriends next how'd I get
here I might kill my ex I still love him
though rather be in jail than alone
wow one of us
it's kind of crazy though when you think
that they have two kids together it's
like maybe chill
maybe just kill on that
Shakira tells Clara to go to hell
while discussing her PL her split from
pick me in a Spanish interview with
Mexican journalist Enrique
I said
Shakira appeared to take aim at her ex's
partner when she said
There's a Place in Hell reserved for
women who don't support other women
again this is something me and you talk
about the blame is 100 on the guy I mean
listen the girl whatever she has no
loyalty she has no [__] obligation to
you yeah your man's the one that [__]
you also who's older she's the 23. he's
he's the 30 whatever 40. I don't know
how old he is just like you can't blame
her it's your dude's fault I'm sorry to
say it but it's all his fault
agreed
next
so Ethan thoughts do we like jam I don't
even know what that means
well do you like strawberry jam do you
like jam Jam's okay so my favorite
strawberry
Jam
So when you say it's not your favorite
what do you like what I mean it's not
what you're using instead of jam
it's not my ideal topping for bread I
mean I'll take butter or cream cheese or
one thing I do damn on toast I want to
abdoris cream cheese and jam together I
love that oh fantastic combination yeah
strawberry agreement there yeah like
strawberry
cream yeah you and Shakira are your
sisters
but yeah but I wouldn't
dude Shakira would beg me she would say
Ethan please and I'll say no I'm with my
wife I love Elitch she's way better than
you it's my love of my life I have two
boys who deserve to see a faithful
loving man dedicated with respect and
admiration to their mother right [__]
you Shakira for even ask me that
you know it's all of love and respect
between me and your mother's some people
are saying the girl is Not Innocent but
it's not her fault she got no blame but
like none
do we know when they started dating for
sure that's the cheating rumors started
swirling because he was seen kissing
someone so soon so everyone was like oh
he must have cheated and then she was
like I knew that he was cheating because
of the jam so according yeah so
according to Shakira yeah never lies
look if you ask me
this 23 sure if she went with a married
guy yeah yeah but the blame
no
reason
she has no loyalty to anybody the the
the responsibility is on your husband
who's the father of your kids you cannot
blame this 23 year old she's just living
her [__] life dude it's some famous
soccer player said hey let's let's do
this thing and she said cool it's not
her fault you've got to look to the real
problem your man is the one that should
have said no your man is the one that
says my loyalty is to my kids
and their mother because it's not just
oh I want to [__] this young girl it's
your kids that suffer from that it's
your kids that grow up without a good
male role model who loves and respects
his partner who loves and respects his
children
go off it's not her fault it's his fault
he's the [__] villain he's been
relaxed back there you know what I mean
it's not been that's the person right
now oh that's the creature yeah he's
preaching right now oh I thought it was
doing his life oh yeah yeah yeah
um here's a comment saying there's also
the power Dynamic yeah don't don't
forget that like he's famous
she's a 23 year old she she's not a
celebrity in it or in any way it's a
hundred percent on him yeah and yeah
by the way thank you Bill Simmons 50
gifted you're a legend Bella
do we have pizza on the way Sam
yes [__] yeah it'll be here in like
30-ish that's what's up that's what's up
um we are at three hours by the way and
um with the level of drunkness I feel
like we have already gotten away with
murder on this episode maybe we should
what I'm waiting for pizza 30 minutes
away why would I end it now
because
because you
um somebody also said he could have lied
and said they weren't together anymore
and that's that's why I'm saying like we
don't fully know is there more details
and and I don't know if I know there's
some speculation yeah these were the
confirmed stuff okay there's like
speculation about her wearing Shakira's
clothes and being in her home and there
are a bunch of conspiracy theories oh
[__] we gotta do the lore you you can we
do it now as part of the show be kind of
interesting it'd be so confusing the
goal is to actually introduce new people
and you're just sloppy drunk in this
intro it's going to be a little odd oh
really yes really
really I can get it together people I
know I'm drunk I'll be sober as [__] for
a minute all right let's give it a try
but but try and pull it together okay
ready this is the intro for the lore
video I'm gonna pull it together I'm
gonna be sober as a gopher maybe let's
remove all the cocktails and uh drinks
from the shot this is for new coming
super right sober as a gopher yup
yeah
are you
oh [__] I forgot all the words nope
love that song though yeah yeah let me
look yup nope lyrics
ever oh see that first line has us learn
yeah I can't say that
nope nope
ever told on a brother
nope ever squeeze the trigger yep yep
ever set a brother up nope ever helped a
brother out when he was down on his luck
yeah you a sap nope
you a brother you a Mac yep
let me hold a couple dollars nope all
right y'all still be popping yellow
colors ready to go y'all still be
popping yellow colors all right we're
ready to go popping all our College
we're gonna tell the question to you
guys in five seconds Dan y'all be
popping yellow color let's just jump
right into the intro to the lore video
we're gonna make our best attempts yeah
to pull together here we go in five four
three two stock rims on the scraper no
stop
paint wetter than the lake
okay that's fine I'm just worried
because you're the nuclear you're you're
reading off of a list okay Ron Burgundy
they have a big ass button with the red
red button on it you are a little bit of
a monkey burgundy that's the problem you
need to do the intro everybody got
choices I choose to get money I'm stuck
to this bread
everybody got choices hey [__] is
choosing them all in their head all
right everybody got choices and keep it
one thousand the life that I chose
everybody got choices these brothers
being hating I already know that I never
go broke no no I'm a state keeping money
yeah yeah and I ain't got it all right
so no no I'ma say do it yeah yeah do the
intro to the lore video if you broke
[Music]
Zach
[Applause]
can you request a Nook do choices
sure can we record the intro I'm dying
for the Nook to do choices that would be
funny everybody
got choices all right I'll do that I'm
gonna do this Dan intro all right here
we go in five four three two
welcome everybody to H3 Lord number two
today we honor
damn the producer who we all love so
well in fact Dan came to us as a humble
live switcher and he turned it into Dan
the wizard he ascended
and um even though he clogs the toilet
from time to time with his massive dumps
laughs
we still love him regardless of
his duties I love him so much
where'd my drink go yo what the [__] who
took my drink
we took it away because we had to shoot
this and if there's a bunch of alcohol
on the table it will give it away should
we start over yeah well yeah I mean that
was that was the first take it wasn't a
bad First Take we I feel like we can do
better that was the best ticket all
right let's try again
all right here we go uh from the top
here we go in five four three two
welcome everybody
act normal
this won't work take three take three
from the top all right from the top oh
no your drink is back no Lina Lina that
was a good idea to remove that that was
a good idea that was a good idea he's
falling away she's only following order
Selena said he's my boss though he's
yeah she's the Nazi concentration cup
guard only following him right they were
executed
were they hanged I believe so yes they
were just following orders right the
whole point of that phrase is that that
wasn't a good enough let me ask you a
question
we can make it keep it going enough
thank you
[Music]
the two of us
okay let's try this again all right here
we go can't you in best app ever all
right here we go in five four three two
welcome everybody to h3lore number two
today we honor our producer dad
laughs
[Laughter]
okay I had it y'all threw me off
oh we're mentioning like new people
this is for new people
[Laughter]
I'm not even kidding I swear I think it
will pull in more people
all right let's try again all right one
more here we go from the top in five
four three two
welcome everybody to H3 lore number two
today we uh honor our producer Dan he is
now ascended to the Wizardry we know him
as today he's a tech wins a tech genius
but when we hired him he was a um
he was just a live switcher basically
for a tech company isn't that right then
uh no that's not accurate really well
okay so correct me then dude don't
embarrass me in my own [__] lore
video I was a technical director and I
and I directed live shows and uh did all
okay so switcher doesn't even
encapsulate the love I mean I was happy
to let it just roll with that but then
you you asked me if that was correct and
it's just not okay well he's also a
contrarian and a [__] hater you
didn't know that
but Dan you know we found Dan at a time
when the podcast was really kind of on
the ropes because we were having a hard
time ascending kind of upgrading at the
time it was me and Ela and it was hard
to find people you could trust people
you could work with who had the
technical know-how and also who were
liable and trustworthy and funny frankly
Dan had the camera presence it was a
charisma
he has the technical ability he is my
Baba Booey
oh that's that's very sweet
Dan is frankly
he's the hat trick he's got you are so
talented technically you have I mean if
you look back at these early episodes
which we're going to show now
the show has come so far
and now you're managing such a kind of a
huge technical Goliath we have this
button I mean this twenty thousand
dollar button that could just erase 20
seconds like it never happened like 1984
memory hole and that's all from Dad and
um we're trying to add too that in the
beginning we just brought the cameras
with us right we set it up right and
then hit the record yeah you just push
the button and then I was hoping for the
best and then spent hours editing if you
remember it was yeah oh yeah that's
right in the early days I would take all
the cameras put them into Adobe and then
I was editing it all bro that was a
nightmare and then um yeah we kept
looking for people to work with on the
spot and I remember there was the one
guy was it Carlo Carlos was a good guy
yeah he's the one who recorded yeah he's
a buddy of mine though he came and
helped us like temporarily but he was
like I might know a guy and then he
recommended then so we worked with Dan
on a freelance basis
and then we're like oh [__] maybe he's
actually good for the full-time position
and we offered it to you Dan and uh you
graciously accepted you trusted us you
you worked with us because you were
employed at the time right I was
employed I was very busy at the time but
uh I was fans of you guys and I was
having a lot of fun doing the podcast
and also I was at that point many years
deep into doing live event
um gigs which if anybody is out there
who has experience with that they know
is a very exhausting stressful lifestyle
of you know 16 to 18 hour days and
working weekends all the time and
everything and uh this seemed like a
great opportunity so I jumped in and
then also very quickly it became a meme
that then would have anything on him in
his backpack like
the MacGyver of podcasts every time we
were like oh we really want to add a
camera here or we really would love to
be able to control it from the laptop
and every time we add a feature and then
he's like yeah I could probably figure
it out I probably have a cable give me a
minute I probably have something in my
backpack so not only is Dan extremely
capable but he's funny he's caring he is
a very uh genuine and sweet
down-to-earth hard-working guy it is Dan
the producer who we've been Grace with
the with the grace of God has brought us
Dan Dan and the producer people ask who
is Dan the producer Dan the producer
people aren't asking that let's go back
in time
to Dan's first appearance on the show
then the producer who made it all
possible
okay that was pretty good Ethan you
think that worked I mean you really
likes to learn a little bit but yeah it
was very heartfelt and it had a good
vibe so I don't know maybe that is
useful it was a hard phone yeah Pam says
it's perfect and he's he's cutting it so
there you go I think I'll watch that
back and I'll be like miserably trash
yeah I mean I was still crying laughing
in the beginning I hope that's not gonna
be weird it's fine whatever nobody cares
I think you hopped out of frame again I
just want to know where that bacon Beach
you know we should watch actually since
we're waiting so you know the elk boys
right okay okay I was gonna say maybe
this one isn't the best yeah to watch
this episode yeah we got the bun it's
just yeah it's just we have so many
other good stories but we already once
to great success I got you but it's just
it's a dicey subject and I just feel
like it's dicey yeah
oh come on it doesn't we have so many
other good things right now all right
we'll skip now goes to Israel we can do
it next week or something when we're I
do suspect that milk was paid off by the
Israeli government to do propaganda I do
Wonder like who would pay for that
because I didn't know they do stuff like
that well I've seen Israel but it does
kind of seem like that they're sort of
like it's worse or something I've seen
Israel running like ads on YouTube and
TV about like four of them like come to
Israel yeah
and I think it's kind of that kind of
Outreach crazy
um and you know Nook is conservative
yeah they kind of encapsulate that
Christian like we need to protect Israel
for when Jesus comes back and kills all
the Jews like it's supposed to be we
can't be having Arabs kill the Jews we
need Jesus to kill all the Jews I liked
in all timelines every Jew dies no
matter who you are
right and this is why I'm
a little reluctant to it you guys want
to watch now goes to Israel why don't we
watch uh or you know we've got to give
the audience this update about a Nook
this is actually a big new big news
oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy
[Applause]
by the way big news
[Music]
he's a popular liberal uh Twitter reply
guy okay yeah if anyone find out he was
like a child star or something real
Predator no he was on dash oh I know
everybody oh Olivia knows yeah yeah Dash
was on this show called Summer break
which was a YouTube reality show for
summertime which was it was like High
School Los Angeles kids he was on two
separate Seasons hey what does the pope
say when he's juicy little boy with that
with the cross
here's a video of it so Donald Trump
um
yeah I'm gonna [__] croak oh God so
Donald Trump
I can't
this man starts his videos oh boy
all right what we can talk about uh
we're gonna talk about it
news this breaking the Nook news a neck
of my heart a Nook of my dick because
he's so hot
blue eyes
some of it might be though
that's [__] beautiful
I was touching I'm just freaking lighted
the fire
oh boy
Whoa all right where what are we looking
at a Nook a Nook we got in contact with
a nug a nook and cranny no the the
singer that has become quite a meme on
the show oh he said so we made contact
with another contact
yes it's big news so is this responsible
message we sent them yeah I mean we we
have been leaving comments on all of his
videos on Tick Tock and Instagram right
yep and yeah
we sent him okay so a Nook finally
acknowledged it he acknowledged us so
shout out to the person who made that
fly me to the moon thing because I
posted that and tagged a Nook and that
seemed to get his attention very well
yeah he replied I'm surprised I'm so
great well hold on he's not sure who is
he's at because you're doing a
collaboration with him right yeah so uh
he hit me up his name is
um Aaron uh he's in Finland
um
we are uh he sent me a news track I
don't want to spoil anything yet but he
sent it to me and he's like will you rip
a uh guitar solo over this dude I heard
your guitar so it's
genuinely so good like I wish we could
play it but I want him to have his
moments right right
um but the song is a great spin on a
uh another great song that a Nook sings
and um
it has that kind of synthwave vibe as
well same Vibe yeah so uh he he said it
should be out soon
enough uh collab coming up well we're
trying and so yeah I mean he did get
back to us
um and the long and short of it is he
said uh he loves that we love his
content so much and he's so happy I love
sharing it that he loves that we love it
so true so he says hello I would like to
thank you very much for the attention
and for giving me this opportunity I
already follow your page on all
platforms King King I already want to
contribute I really want to contribute
to your platform
but I live in Italy and our time is
different
so is he an Italian king
yeah uh he lives in Italy I believe his
immigrant he he may or may not be uh I
know he's we love immigrants don't we
he's either uh first or second
generation from uh Thailand do we love
immigrants Dan of course because we
wouldn't be here without him baby you're
married to one yep
never thought about it that way
[Music]
all right
so he says I really want to go Jupiter
platform I live in Italy and our time is
different also I have a full-time job so
I don't have much time most of the time
I have
time is spent singing I love this the
idea that every single moment of this
man's Freedom he might be telling them
[Music]
John Lennon is that you yeah
John Lennon please come back we need to
mix them in that compilation
[Music]
most of the time I have time is spent
singing so I think it's inconvenient for
an interview but it's the use of my work
whether it's my singing voice various
Clips I'm very happy to let you use it
or play it in all respects well frankly
a Nook I love you but you do not own the
rights to any of them that was what I
said the other day that's straight up
not your [__] it was like that's very
generous but you also don't own any of
the music that is 100 not in your
jurisdiction yeah but we appreciate it
[Music]
I'm starting to feel like I'm way more
sober and you're like you're sober as a
gopher I'm on [__] Mars right now I
can tell yeah the food is going to be
here in just a few minutes I'm literally
on the moon of Saturn
which one that's a new place I believe
it's called um
uh I'm on these nuts Europa Europa Deez
Nuts is uh Europa is a Jupiter moon Dan
whatever bro it doesn't matter I'm it's
strong cares where Moon it is
oh I know [__] sorry
he says but if it's the use of my work
whether it's my singing voice very
Eclipse I'm very happy to let you use
your plating respect that's not your
right to Grant thank you again for the
opportunity you have given me I
apologize for some inconvenience may you
all have happy God bless you so what I
want from a Nook
I want to just I just want him for a
five minute call you know I'm not asking
for uh a lot of his time from his busy
prolific day he's been singing but you
can also pre-record it if we need like
his time zone dick
[Music]
that's funny
because I'm because he's [__] hot
okay that's the joke there it's not a
joke it's not a joke it's a real desire
thing
right back
yeah uh this is the cover of Abbey Road
not get back so it's a little a little
bit of a stretch
yes sir
[Music]
we'll get right back
is it I mean the referencing get back
though
but that song isn't on Abby Road it's
written in a Nook vocab a Nook
vernacular
we'll get right back
crickets go ahead and play the cricket
all right uh the pizza is arriving I
think we should drive towards the uh the
ending here yeah why because the pizza's
here so
so it's time to end the show
ER listen to your father three and a
half hours
considering the amount of alcohol yeah
we have we have cruise through this
episode mostly in your demon for that
what he keeps putting my dad over Dad
Dad Dad Dad Dad
I'll be tap I'll be river dancing my ass
out of here
in an Uber
can we we're not sober enough to drive
I'll be driving at 90 miles per hour
listening to Highway stars going out man
oh my God no of course I won't be
driving of course thank you for
clarifying you know I want to just
reflect a little bit if we can on the
specialness of St Patrick's Day me as an
American person paying homage and with
the utmost respect to the Irish people
and their culture the Saint Patrick who
did a genocide on snakes why I don't
know he [__] murdered millions of
snakes there was no reason for that who
were the snakes they're minded on
[__] business they rodents they ra
they they you know they're an important
role in the ecosystem
what happens when you kill all the
snakes
then you have a right infestation if
it's a saint no he's a [__] idiot
say Patrick's a [__] idiot dude
dumbass
looser
idiot dumbass he goes oh I walk the
pastures with the Sheep shut up idiot I
play Minecraft
Saint Patrick
I have a Redstone Minecraft machine that
kills sheep and you're walking the
pastures with them fool you fool [__]
them dude
mm-hmm
I do want to say though St Patrick if
you are listening I will [__] you up
in a physical 1v1 I will literally
overpower you
take you to the floor and make you
submit
if this Muslim Infinity War happens that
I was talking about right your wish
could come true yeah you think so we'll
come out of one of the portals I mean
Jesus I mean not Matthew are supposed to
team up so right I mean you never know
so wait is sheamuson
Jesus on the good side yeah no Jesus is
he missing a lot or cool
Jesus is yeah we believe Jesus is going
to come back like a badass yeah and said
Jesus Allah and Moses our Vibes oh yeah
yeah Moses
tag me out dog they're all gonna stop
Thanos right yo Allah hook me up brother
boom and then Jesus comes out [__] you
[__] wow Jesus is gonna fly from heaven
with Thor's hammer
and [__] [__] up
it's gonna be so sick all right let's
start the outro music he's like yo I'm
the Son of God [__] bring it up he's
like yo I'm the Son of God [__] what'd
you do burn a bush who cares happy St
Patrick's Day everybody it's been a
great St Patrick's Day it's been so fun
tonight
I love you shout out
to me
no can I be real I don't remember
anything we've been here for three over
three hours well over three years what
the [__] have we been doing
luckily it's documented
you get you gave like a 90 minute
Symposium for you it's all on camera
yeah remember String Theory yeah String
Theory remember talking about that you
guys want to come in Monday yo we need
to get drunk everywhere
oh boy wait do you guys have more
questions about the theoretical physics
I'll ask you off camera
um
behind finishing an episode of the
podcast and how do we do it okay
Universe with multiversity there is a
Multiverse where Ethan Bizarro Ethan has
wrapped it up and moved on Wow but at
this universe here I don't think it's
cool to call him Bizarro well Bizarro in
the sense that it's not discriminating
against other Ethan Ethan hate yeah I
like that no Ethan hate thanks I need I
think the fans could learn from you
know Ethan I hate you [__]
[Laughter]
all right we're going to Vegas we'll see
y'all next week
thank you Irish people
[Music]
laughs